foreign
[Applause]
that's a beautiful day though here study
beautiful day out here in Los Angeles by
about 65 coming here to the traffic this
is heating up a little bit on the 10. if
you can avoid that
foreign
with some sweet Tunes it is Dream On by
Aerosmith
actually today's app is sponsored by the
one and only gamer sub Nation
let's go let's go let's take a sip from
the sub yes and by the way today they're
doing the
24-hour free trial free sample they give
you a free set it's awesome
can you even show that it's still
graphic
you know what I mean
yeah I guess anime titties is that cool
I don't know breasts hell yeah red hair
does that red hair I always show this
side because I go oh this side's a
little crap
it's just a drawing like come on what
are we
Hey listen I got no problem with that
it's just YouTube has been pretty hard
for the week at least so maybe not
all right so anyway
um Dan is not here
he is taking a personal day to uh it's
personal he's fine but he's a good man
he's a good man yeah
uh get seeds right here already dropping
50 gifted sub y'all are nuts man thank
you
also Rebecca Black was supposed to be
here today she had to reschedule at the
last minute as you know that happens
sometimes yeah Dynamic live experience
it's a dynamic lots of moving Parts in
this world we live in
and uh well she is dead to me no I'm
just kidding it's all good we're
rescheduling right Olivia hopefully next
week right
oh next week that'd be great
yeah we're trying to get it in before
she leaves for Europe okay that'd be
awesome I hope so I was really looking
forward to it I know I was looking for
and um
lots of
lots of interviews oh I'm being very
persistent
yeah yeah the people need it
but uh yeah hopefully we'll have her in
next week
um
what is this
a new YouTube feature yeah it gives you
this
celebrate the first Super Chat from
Emily oh we're celebrating you girl hell
yeah Emily what did she say I mean
wouldn't that be a better way to
celebrate it it's just to actually read
what she said it doesn't say that Emily
thanks for the Super Chat we're not
reading it but we're celebrating it but
I'm sure it was super thoughtful and we
appreciate it
but I'm not reading it hell no I'm not
reading that [__] no no not reading that
[__]
okay let's go did any does anyone trying
to actually find it yeah I'm trying okay
Emily that's right we actually have no
way of reading it sorry Emily I love
that we're celebrating it oh yeah for
those of you guys who found them it's
the thought that counts you know it
doesn't matter what she said and that's
it that's that's exactly and that's what
YouTube is saying basically listen sorry
sorry Dan apologizes
um so the steamies yeah is next week is
that right on Wednesday is that right
that is correct yep and we I don't know
if I've confirmed I think I did but tana
and Jeff are coming in you guys to
celebrate the 2022 steamy award that is
so cool it's a star-studded event folks
bring your finest this is a black tux
formal event
gowns and Tux did they know that they do
know that wow to impress oh my God you
know Tana is gonna like really impress
Jeff says he's gonna get a talks what
are you wearing a tux that's what I
always wear like a nice one no actually
rent it it's horrible horribly fit dog
[__] I'm not gonna buy a nice touch
you know what I mean
maybe if it goes over well because our
dream is always going to happen you
should but I think so I think it will go
over great but our Dream before our
breakup with Trisha was to always do the
steamies have a live Auditorium event
so that's the dream so if we can find
some good stable hosts I mean magic
could be happening
[Music]
so that's exciting oh speaking of which
there's the steamy form so as you guys
know the steamies are selected by the
people
oh we got is this Emily's oh no this
isn't Emily sorry Emily but we got one
for Jax
Jack says hey guys it's my 25th birthday
so happy to join in family yeah and
family and thank you Jax and Emily
Emily is probably like I only have 10
days to live and I I just really
I would die happy if you would just read
this message we're like sorry
[Applause]
hey Gabe what's going on Nice Slice
I'm enjoying my pizza
Oh What a Beautiful experience over
there where are you eating
accommodated which is good which I enjoy
because Avatar sucks bro I'm so with you
dude I'm right I'm so [__] with you
on this day so you don't like James
Cameron at all though it's not just
Avatar you're not down with the guy
either
but he directed Titanic which is a good
movie despite Avatar which is a piece of
[__] right right right
that's interesting and did you see the
first avatar is that where your animus
comes from
I don't really see the first one the
second one I watch it and I I fall
asleep in the movie which I think is
boring that's why it's a piece of [__]
it was long man wasn't it like three and
a half hours or something three and a
half hours Jesus and so how deep in is
it when you fell asleep How deep did you
make it
like almost towards the middle okay so
they didn't get you you gave it a good
shot they just they couldn't keep you up
tried it yeah yeah I'm saying I'm right
there with you man [__] James Cameron
can I have can I ask you this are you
aware that there's lots of like Avatar
porn out there were you aware of that
phenomenon
yeah I have no clue yeah people find the
avatars sexy like the big blue bodies
and stuff and um probably yeah probably
so I was I guess my question is do you
find the avatars to be sexy or weird or
or in between
I think it's weird yeah yeah I'm with
you there bud are you going to Google it
tonight
yeah maybe
yeah just to find out you know you want
to know what you're picking out on
what slice you got what toppings that
just cheese pepperoni oh man classic
dude you eat good brother
your skin looks good though it looks
like healthy
what's your skincare routine yeah
much
that puts good notion every day and when
I shower I put temp Conditioner helps
help my hair stop
okay okay awesome we love that
we love a good hair care system don't
you uh yeah
all right well [__] doing anything are
we doing anything fun this weekend
probably have Korean barbecue this
weekend that's awesome bro I love you I
love you and your family your whole
weeks are just revolve around food and
that's something I just totally identify
with I love that oh yeah yeah
how many slices you can you kick back in
one sitting
nice [__] baby [__]
and do you think that folding the pizza
makes the experience go too fast
sometimes I like to keep it unfolded to
savor the pizza
by the way it's dripping it's dripping
it's not dripping on you is it
okay good I start that thing
okay I see it I see and is that just
dripping on the floor there or where is
that grease going
what's going on my plate okay okay good
man good man
[Music]
all right Gabe you enjoy that pizza it's
always a pleasure
[__] baby [__]
is in my ass [__] [__] put your tongue
in my butthole baby
we like to butt lip no pink eye please
[__]
make sure that ass is clean so I don't
get pink eye
laughs
well
you okay sorry yeah
hasta la vista [__]
hasta la vista baby
share my ass
[__]
[Music]
all right thank you
thank you to White clock game everybody
it's always a pleasure always a pleasure
we have an update from Dan because he
refuses to just take something damn what
the frick he sent us uh the actual
message which Emily said Ela you look so
slay today oh dude I found the message
that is actually from another Emily okay
correct that movie yeah Dan I didn't
want to say anything but there's like 50
Emily's for some reason that are
celebrating the first time chat today
and I can't find Emily P it's fine bro
it's lost she's gonna die she's gonna
die miserable now because you guys
couldn't find the message also Dan
called out Gabe for his Avatar slander
now Gabe's right Dan you're not even
here Dan we never take the day off
seriously we didn't ask for your
permission bro we didn't ask for your
opinion we're actually uh a bunch of the
things to watch it tonight actually
what's that so we're all going to watch
Avatar tonight most of us really wait
again Ian's gonna watch it again oh my
gosh it's gonna be first time viewing
three and a half hours again I have to
tell you it's so good cam loved it I
[__] loved it I can't believe it Dan
liked it which is a lot yeah yeah I love
it Dan really liked it I would say yeah
I could tell he didn't love it he barely
had bad stuff to say about it we were
losing him for bad stuff Dan was in a
weird place because he was talking [__]
about it for years he couldn't he can't
say that he likes it too much you know
that's why I'm not even gonna see it Dan
straight up was like I'm really
disappointed because I want to go again
with you guys yeah
oh my God I'm not seeing that dog I
don't know yeah I'm still saying no well
you didn't even open you didn't read his
message for verbatim AB he said okay
he's a [__] idiot for this take oh I
felt too bad
um thank you to Taylor
your makeup so far lots of love thank
you oh yeah I want to say you look so
sweet queen thank you so much
oh thanks thanks for saying that thank
you
I've been experimenting and I feel like
you know slowly I'm starting to
understand a little bit about makeup the
pictures you posted here you look so
loud
looked awesome literally look at this
thank you oh she's ugly you know what I
went to uh I went to a Sephora and I
want to shout out the the girl that was
helping me there
because I just like um I was like maybe
I'll grab a couple things and I had no
idea what to get and she helped me and
she was like helping me find the right
color for me that's nice and then only
at the end she was like by the way a
huge fan and I was like oh you didn't
tell me the whole time so but she did
you good yeah she did she was so helpful
so shout out
I am her biggest fan
um
so there that is uh nice to see Gabe
always now because Rebecca kind of had
to reschedule on us we're kind of
floundering here or I mean it's just
going to be one of those episodes which
I think is Sometimes good sometimes I
think it turned out to be the best so
we're just kind of freestyling I mean no
we have a lot to talk about but
there is some last minute
improvisational going into this one
um and so what I happened was when I we
found out at like 10 a.m 10 p.m last
night and I had to quickly change the
event because we
we had Rebecca Black in the thumbnail
yeah and so I did what any uh
you know Wise Creator would do I blacked
out her silhouette but a question mark
and said big big huge announcement
massive announcement I saw that Tyrone
and I was wondering what's the
announcement got a click to find out
there is an announcement it's Midway
through the episode so no skipping
a retention time is very important
there's going to be surprises all
throughout this podcast so no skipping
no you're gonna play the drum rolls for
later will play until the middle of the
episode oh yeah so I forgot to say the
steamies
um voting form is up now this is a for
the People by the people right we do not
we don't do none of this
Holy Wood this like oh Shady back rooms
uh you know all different flavors you
know Fouseytube creator of the year it's
like who [__] who voted for that yeah
nobody because it's a farce I felt
worthless Dance I'm sorry real quick
Dan's taking over his computer again he
always man he always trips me oh my God
because I start fighting with him over
the mouse and I don't realize damn why
are you taking over the computer he's
helping out he's trying to find he's
he's really dedicated to finding Emily's
message oh so he's doing it yeah your
computer yeah but he never gives me a
heads up so I'm like I'm always pulling
the mouse thinking that's so creepy and
someone else do it who's like not
producing the show okay I can't do that
well anyway um how do we are you gonna
spam this in the chat are you going to
Tweet it how are we going to get this to
the people uh I'm pinning it in chat
right now
um
I need to vote later on
now hold on make sure this form is
accessible because I see a what do you
mean dude what sorry Dan's talking to me
like Morpheus he opened up a notepad
sheet and he says search the spreadsheet
oh my God oh my God in the spreadsheet
yeah I'm following the rabbit Dan
I've ordered it all right then you're
derailing our show bro your hero you're
not I I'm the one doing it all right
y'all just work on your thing over there
and they're even allowed to break into
our computer on his day off I mean show
up at work and work harder that could be
a federal offense you know okay but so
yeah we're taking the votes we have
spiciest drama
worst National here let me let me pull
it up so y'all can check it out
we got some great categories this year
new categories old categories lots of
nominees spiciest drama
a huge category man I think people
should really take their time I want to
do it tonight like really taking my time
voting here yeah this is the big this is
the big one previous years are kind of
ultimate category was most dramatic
creator that has fallen in importance
this one's gonna be so hard yeah there's
some really good ones you forget each
one here is like Logan Paul coffee Zilla
liver King exposed for using steroids
Kanye goes Nazi that's great try guys
exposed for cheating couples vs kiwi
Farm gambling banned on Twitch Ethan
Klein versus NRA that was wild all of
right wing Twitter dobrik sued by Jeff
oh and then this guy's Slicker I've even
forgot about this one steals money for
his gambling addiction I actually
completely forgot about that so that's a
he I can't even guess which one's gonna
win there
honestly I can't even guess that was the
beginning and then there was like so
much twitch drama I it was confusing to
even follow right with this it started
with Slicker steals money and then there
were like a million other things yeah
yeah it was all connected
so that's gonna be huge and worse
National brain rot discourse
lots of categories There Will Smith was
this year I mean like last year 2020.
whoa
the ruining a generation of young men
award and that's okay that's easy
you think so well actually not but yeah
it's as shitty as all those people are
there's one that's to stand above no
dumbest fat man bad ela's ugly oh I love
this one
there's actually four nominees if you
can believe that I do believe it and you
know what Aiden wait Aiden Ross is not
here
well he's redeemed right no he belongs
in there I mean he did you know I mean
he had a moment did he say we were
discussing it
his homie said it but it was still a
moment she'll consider it him because
it's his homie
just for ease I can't say Aiden Ross is
home you know what I mean
happy 31st to Emily P like if one of you
guys said something about someone Ethan
will be taking the [__] you know it's
just kind of like it's a family
yeah can we is it too late to Adam I I
can add him yeah it's just you know
let's not exclude sweet Aiden Ross my
sweet sweet I'm not saying that I would
vote for him but he's not going to win
no but it's just a fact in my opinion
biggest cringe moment there is a lot
Happening Here
golly dream face reveal Addison Ray's
dad's beef with young gravy Dot
that's painful Aiden Ross sniffing
Andrew Tate's hair
Doja cat beefing with Noah schnapp I
want to forget about that I know but we
can't it's the steamies
Adam Levine sexting women you remember
how embarrassing that was that's crazy
Pete Davidson getting Kim Kardashian's
kids tattooed on him which is I guess I
read he laser removed them idiot stupid
idiot
what an idiot that's so embarrassing
keemstar feeding beef jerky
worst influencer scam worst apology
worst award show there's actually this
one is actually there's only one oh my
God I love the worst apology just
thinking about each one makes me so
I'm like giggly inside hey you know I
apologize for the lack of options for a
worse reward show it is kind of just a
write-in at this moment
[Applause]
most Shameless click bait okay see even
I'm up for an award okay
most unhinged Tick-Tock account
this is great we got PNP the put Bean
beanut butter peanut butter Craig he's
the guy who put his dick in the back
okay and then we found out he's like
he's like a sex uh criminal
yeah you know he uh he is I think right
did we confirm that I can say that uh
kinda sorta
bro
all right yeah no there was there was
definitely allegations made against him
oh really yeah yeah okay there are
allegations that made us uncomfortable
okay
how about that that's happy yeah that's
fair
okay worst influencer boxing moment
greatest Redemption art now here we're
oh I loved something what the hell
happened dear God somebody please do
something award
um this includes the girl who broke her
back at twitchcon
what do we have an update on her is she
like okay I'll check right now oh my God
the Gabby Hannah thing was wild oh yeah
dude Gabby Hannah's house yeah or when
amaranth all right that was crazy how is
she doing now she's doing good I think
that's good she's participating she's
made it out of that situation she is
yeah she's I saw that she's doing
announcing or something oh like I was
like oh my God interviews
uh put Logan Paul's you know Pig and
found near dead most dramatic Creator
and you know it's still here and again
I've I've been nominated again
[Music]
don't you think Philly D should be in
this too I mean that guy's just a little
so dramatic
all right Fair now so guys get the votes
in it's a huge year it's a fun year it's
a fantastic
beer and I think all of our nominees uh
[Music]
it's gonna be exciting yes
now I want to say
that Ela has not seen this can I watch
this the chestnuts roasting over open
fire yes I this whole thing
oh wait I thought you all said it was
getting clean oh no no I'm sorry I
thought that was the clip hold on let me
add the clip
so we have a clip I can watch yeah
I wouldn't I wouldn't Chestnut we'll hit
it Zach
I gotta show you the video too
we actually have someone who um
transcribed it
let me see if I can hit the lyrics
perfectly what is this song
this is
um a nuke who's a Superstar singer from
Thailand
and um
here play play I think I got the the
lyrics here go ahead
children fight
Jack Frost sleeping at your nose
okay I see it
Chester's rotting over Eon Phi
[Music]
Jack Frost
our soul
s
constantly
actually can y'all link me the yeah
thank you Zach that's a
quite enough can you link me the
original video I gotta show Ila yeah I'm
looking for right now it sounds like
something from like years ago like Elvis
yeah you know he's the real deal and he
has the super crazy yeah we got
chestnuts in chat so people aren't
really involved in this
but um
he's the real deal and he has this
insane face filter like I don't think
anyone actually knows what he looks like
I don't know if you guys remember the
story there was a Japanese girl who had
a motorcycle vlog super cute young
Japanese yes yes yes yes and then it
turned out it was like an old dude yeah
he's like accidentally they saw it in a
reflection yes dude and it was just some
old do with like beautiful hair he did
have beautiful hair long hair
and I'm getting that vibe from our boy a
nuke a little bit so the the fake girl
was like a filter I don't remember what
yeah it was just like a really good face
filter
so here here's the video that kind of
you know changed the world and this is
for ela's benefit
foreign
[Music]
yeah we can't go any further that's
apparently all we can get away with
before getting uh I love it claimed by
the chestnut big Chestnut
oh yeah this is this is the vibe I'm
getting from him yes this story blew my
mind so look at this like beautiful
young girl on a on a motorcycle trip
around Japan yeah and she had all these
admirers and people who were super into
her and this is this is this is her
isn't that awesome yeah I love it
so I I'm feeling like I don't think
anybody knows what a nuke really looks
like you know what I mean yeah it's hard
to find anything that's unfiltered also
Adriana seems to be doing good the
streamer her recovery seems to be going
well she can walk she's walking around
yes in her most recent Instagram post
for her yeah Chestnut
it just like showed up out of nowhere
like does he do other stuff yeah he has
so many great songs but there we have
it's hard to work around the copyright
claims because he's such an icon then is
that on Tick Tock yeah he blew up on
Tick Tock for that hauntingly beautiful
rendition of chestnuts is chestnuts a
real song chestnuts roasting over open
fire it's like a classic Christmas song
okay yeah and he's
you know he's getting he's trying I love
it yeah I love it too
yeah it's just a really beautiful thing
so I wanted to introduce you to that and
so you know you might hear it a few
times right Zach a lot of times oh my
friend yeah
um windows by the way is a fan of the
show that's right the operating system
Windows what is wishing AB a happy
anniversary yeah super random did that
happen Bill Gates if you're out there
you're a disgusting creep according to
Dan
no he is okay no he is yeah we did go
down there yeah he is yeah allegedly
I'll just say that when dealing with
Bill Gates
what a night eh yeah they sent me an
edit today too congrats you guys this
was our anniversary this week yeah
yesterday wait what how many years uh
three years married wow been together
for nine years
and beautiful anything fun yesterday
uh you know what we're sick Lena was
sick yeah that's it oh you were sick I
realized you feeling better today
definitely much better thank you and I I
hate to be vulgar and I apologize but um
vampire
[Music]
I was dying at your eggplant story oh my
God yeah and actually a lot of people
reached out and they've had similar
experiences really and it worked for
them all eggplants wow some people said
eggplants and others said just like a
similar experience where somebody like
did some kind of like a reading on them
and it went away right after
that was really funny
um these damn warts sick signal of the
devil maybe you need this for that bring
on down that eggplant there and we're
gonna curse this demon that's the Holy
Spirit now I says myself I heard there's
this thing that lesbians do when they
touch each other's vaginas they call it
scissoring
the only thing being scissored is my
soul and hack demons
laughs every time a lesbian scissor
another poor child get a finger full of
warts amen it's not okay amen stop the
fear and we what we gotta do is cut out
the scissor ring to cut out the words
amen
I like lesbians don't get me wrong the
TA the category is excellent but the
gospel is what the gospel is dear amen
how Hallelujah Lord help me Jesus I seen
myself a lesbian with a strap-on dildo
time's the size of my own car and I said
to myself David
what what you some man when you could
when a woman wears a strap-on like that
dude that's Unholy
God did not plan for that
giant strap-ons were not in God's plan
amen
amen Jesus is good damn these words
they also they must be big fans of the
show because they reference a few memes
in their response tweets and then today
they tweeted this out all right sent in
chat oh my God why are you so good at
this character I was born for it I'm
gonna open a church I like that you said
lisbons yeah cause you know hilarious
you know what it is they tweeted this
Welcome to our Windows wamily what the
frick oh you got like Goku yeah yeah I
like Dragon Ball Z yeah they're fans
yeah but it's just some intern right
it's just some social media yes like yo
if you're really somebody send us some
computers what's up well whoever it is
you might have just got them fired by
yeah they're probably going to talk
about Bill Gates yo whoever you are
running this
maybe don't do it again I appreciate
your sacrifice no no family baby prove
to us that you really have clout over
there and send us computers now utter
carelessness of the Twitter organization
thank you nice to hear from you though
Microsoft yeah thank you appreciate that
what is this oh my God this is is this
real
this explains it Bill Gates what is that
your guys's wedding lord well no wonder
huh well I'd rather not speak about that
Bill Gates out your wedding golly
that is satanic
diamonds Diamond demons everywhere is
that a high job loads
help me
only Jesus is the right savior
lord lord lord look at this demonic
wedding right here boy oh Jesus
[Music]
kissed his old Nash this is not a joy a
wedding is a serious as a heart attack
no smiling having fun demonic words you
ain't never seen hard no surprise the
girl got warts on her finger after
having a wedding jubilant like that now
um
you know what's wrong Jesus was missing
from that wedding
whatever the next live show you do a
little you open the show like this
that'd be awesome fire sermon what they
used to call that you guys anyone
remember their History AP there was like
sermons like fire brimstones yeah fire
and brimstones I don't know what is that
back in the day there was like a whole
genre of preaching called fire and
brimstone where it was just like that
where like people come and they're like
possessed no it was just super radical
like Christian like uh puritanical dude
like everyone's going to hell who's it's
kind of like West uh Westborough what is
it called Westborough yeah so it's kind
of like a whole bunch of those guys run
around
oh my God what do you know
don't do that this woman don't have
Jesus in her life she knows nothing
except Jesus ah Damon I can see hell's
fire in your eyes
you need to repent
and shame on you
shame on you you're
yeah
um actually a funny I don't know if it's
funny
a little segue
we always joke about Stephen Crowder
being gay
and obviously it's not nice to speculate
about people's sexuality which you know
I agree with
it's just because of how he's like
but uh
vocally like against it right dude he's
like a really deeply religious Christian
and he does he's on all this like
grooming trans people
don't say gay he's on all this super
homophobic super transphobic [__]
and it was been a running gag but
actually I saw this clip for the first
time I even sent it to Hassan I was like
have you seen this [__] and he had not
seen it and he was freaking out too
now oh my God again
I'm showing this not not to um
not to goof on the man because I I think
he needs to come out and be like imagine
if Crowder came out how joyous his life
would be
that would be really something for
society and he could be a gay he could
be a gay icon he couldn't do so much
good he could he could be a gay icon he
also has like bear status he's pretty
big his heart he has a weak heart so he
probably need to
probably need to be gentle with him but
that he's a tender lover and people like
that too Dave rubin's a married gay guy
yeah well I'm not talking about him
Jordan uh I'm talking about Crowder I
know it upsets you
but here is Crowder from a couple years
ago having a
surprisingly candid moment with his
audience sometimes you have to make hard
decisions and sometimes you think you
have to make hard decisions and it's
just wrong I'm afraid of that
uh I'm afraid of
I'm afraid frankly I used to have a bad
temper I'm afraid of it coming back I'm
afraid of Mr Hyde rearing is ugly
bisexual head that was a that was a
short phase
um no I'm afraid that is literally not a
joke
it's so surprising what does he says so
Jackal you know Miss Dr Jacqueline Mrs
Hyde okay yeah Mr Hyde it's like the the
story of this doctor who invents a
potion and then it turns him into a
woman okay and then a man so it's a
refreshing split personality yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he's free sometimes
you have to make hard decisions and
sometimes huh is that the story
[Music]
yeah I was thinking
oh my God bro there's like some 90s
comedy you're thinking of a j station
video you're thinking of the gay motion
dude I swear to God I literally think
there was like a 90s comedy
yeah this one bro why did I why did this
concern my mind look at this [__]
yeah this was it man wait
I swear to God Dr Jekyll and Mrs Hyde
this is from 1995. you're you're the
only person
I know what the [__] it's crazy
yeah I don't know I don't even remember
anything about it
so there it is a great great film
I guess it hit me with oh yeah so check
this out this was the Fan's response to
it because his live chat I gotta watch
it again though yeah yeah yeah yeah here
I think you have to make hard decisions
and it's just wrong I'm afraid of that
uh I'm afraid of
I'm afraid frankly I used to have a bad
temper I'm afraid of it coming back I'm
afraid of Mr Hyde rearing is ugly
bisexual head that was a smoke that was
a short phase
um no I'm afraid wow so like not a joke
in fact so much so that this is the live
chat and this is that this is very sad
and this explains why
you know he he is not embracing his um
the part of him that loves to kiss and
touch and and fondle and be loved and
love a man is there really a real that's
that is really sad well read the chat he
says he's he looks at this person shame
on crowd of her being bisexual he said
he's bisexual Crowder's disgusting
did you just say your bisexual phase is
that a joke
did Crowder just admit to having a
bisexual face
did you just say you fear your bisexual
self coming back like you had sex with a
guy wow did you honestly yeah so did you
honestly expect an answer Beyond fingers
and ears mailbox actually is not real
sentiment shame on you Crowder the Bible
says it is an Abomination load what you
did shame on you for being bisexual so
this is why and this is this is actually
really sad it is I actually feel bad
um and he is religious and I guess he
has a religious upbringing so this man
cannot be who he wants to be
he cannot that's crazy that he said that
openly like
and that his fans suck so much yeah I
know that's it like if the reaction was
different and more encouraging maybe it
would talk about it more yeah I wonder
because it's still up on his channel
it's not like he he didn't cut it took
it away but he's never talked about it
again
yeah it's sad and it's also interesting
because he's you know so hateful so
hateful yeah
but this is what happens when you make
content like this it's you Garner these
hateful little trolls goblins that just
[__] yeah they judge you you know
what I mean what happened to the judge
not he's been the most judgment judgeful
[__] in the world bro we should
have a pride minute for Crowder
before we do that yeah something very
interesting that may
I'm looking into it now but he voiced
brain on Arthur and brain had a part
where he sung uh Dr Jekyll and miss Mr
Hyde
coincidence
he did a voice in Arthur he did a voice
on Arthur yeah yeah no I don't know well
that character sung Dr Jekyll and Mr
Hyde in one of the episodes
okay
uh-huh what does it mean the plot I mean
we're just talking about Crowder and Dr
Jekyll Mr Hyde I don't know maybe maybe
he suggested that that hands started a
little bit of his own flavor into the
character
maybe he saw the 1995 flick Dr Jones on
Mr side
that could be it all right we need to
have a pride minute for Crowder before
we get actually you know what let me do
that because this [__] goes on forever
the sermon listen I gotta thank Gamers
up
we love gamer sup
[Music]
um
and today
they're giving away free samples
I don't know why I can't open this link
is this not a clickable link guys
they're giving away free samples for 24
hours
should open
I love gamer sub it doesn't open on my
it's not opening
now when you say Chinese in the chat it
opened Olivia just opened it too it's
weird we tested we tested this morning
yeah I mean it all right well send me
the link dude I said it doesn't work for
me I sent it okay
oh it was you as then yeah I was like
then
um
listen I love me some gamer sup
up
I drink it every day it's got energy
it's got caffeine it's hydrating it's
got Electro electricity electricity you
don't even have to think about it
electrolytes well I found out that when
I'm drinking coffee I start coughing
like crazy like it really makes my
stomach acidic your GERD makes my girl
go crazy yeah not this this is actually
hydrating and keeps me awake so if you
need a game all night you need to work
all night or you just want to taste your
beverage you can watch Housewives all
night totally bowed
Gamers up is the way that H3 Nation does
it
now when you said you sent me the link
AB what exactly did you mean by that I
saw something this is a link to the dock
no it's that's the adderies in there we
put in the dock so they're one of we
made a new dog so they're probably wrong
bro yeah I need a link to their website
to their website this link does not work
right here
you see what I'm saying to be okay give
me a sec
gamer sup
that link also doesn't work thank you
here it is guys if you go to gamer sup
hold on let me tell the link
oh yeah yeah gamer sub star GG slash H3
gamersubs.gg H3 go over here check this
out you get a free sample
zero dollars also I think
hold on
I gotta make sure that this is right
shipping information
can you do a return on a free sample I
don't want it anymore take it back
that's awesome
let me read this
um it tastes great it's got so many
great flavors I always hit black cherry
me too my favorite
I love it
but I know there's a lot of enthusiasm
for mango back here oh yeah it's the
best one for sure it's got no sugar in
it so it's great for replacing sugary
beverages
just it's awesome it's awesome it's a
perfect drink
I love it so go to gamersup.ggh3 get
your free sample for the next 24 hours
all you have to do is hit add to the
cart
hit checkout enter your mailing address
and enter your email address
and all you have to do is add your you
don't have to wait
it says you
says you have to add your credit card or
anything so
does that mean
that you don't or that you don't yeah
so I that's what I thought you didn't
have to add your credit card dude
it will be zero dollars it's a just
straight up free zero dollars
they just want you to try it because
they're so sure that you're gonna love
it
and if you missed the 24 hour window you
can always buy it for always 10 off with
code H3
so you know what we did this when we
first started working with them with the
free samples and everybody absolutely
loved it so I encourage y'all go to
gamersups
dot GG slash H3 links in the description
get yourself a free sample love that
love gamer stuff for free
yes
I see lots of people saying doing it
right now do it apparently the first
time we did it they did like tens of
thousands of free samples which is kind
of favorite but it's like actually a
really great marketing it's super smart
but I was like God that's gonna cost him
a fortune right
but apparently it's the product's so
good that people go do it and it pays
off
all right thank you thank you to gamer
sup Nation
[Music]
[Applause]
um moving on of course from We're of
course stay tuned we have a big big huge
announcement massive announcement coming
up not yet Zach uh coming along more
close to the middle of the episode maybe
back middle but I'll keep you guys
updated the prices throughout that's
what I want to encourage you guys to to
Really uh think
to think it did think on yeah to no to
believe so okay let's have a pride
minute for Crowder
Feel The Beat guys
you know it's just uh we're at a gay
club
the beat is just getting you moved you
just want to dance tonight you know what
I mean you just want to dance with the
Bros and it's not even about hooking up
it's not even about you know sex it's
just about being it's a big game man
it's about being yourself it's about
being free you know what I mean a
married gay guy it's about finding a
community where you can be yourself
amongst peers who love and accept you as
who you are science is gay that's what
this is all about science is gay and
Stephen I want this
Feel The Beat Stephen I know you feel
the beer and this is what I need for you
Stephen
bisexuality wasn't a phase bro you liked
it and we all know you liked it cried
month Feel The Beat
Feel The Beat yes and I got news for you
that means you get it that's right
Stephen
Stephen be your gay self
Mr Hyde Mr Hyde and then you're you're
dancing Mrs
this is hard we are that pretty head
come on you see over at the bar a cute
guy he's Gruff and tough like you and
he's looking at you he looks away real
fast you keep feeling the beat but then
you look back at the bar you catch eyes
again
he comes over to you you're too nervous
to approach him right because this is
all new to you Stephen Crowder
you wouldn't dare to approach another
man you're not ready for that he comes
up to you big muscles hairy chest cowboy
hat this is a real alpha male he says
are you here by yourself
Steven's sweating he doesn't know what
to say but he sure knows he's [__]
I'm not gay no more
is that it
is that musician the minute is over it's
over back in the closet freaks
Crowder you disgust me
that bisexual phase of yours was on a
bombing nature Lord read your comments
and Let Jesus Smite you down
Stephen Crowder you are an Abomination
how you kiss the man that and then
Katrina happened
what the hell do you think you are you
have blood on your hands shame on you
I'm just reading comments now shame on
you Crowder for being a bisexual
[Music]
you there you are
and now do like all of us
and get in a Loveless marriage have kids
and never truly love your partner or be
fulfilled in life and that's the way
Jesus planned for it amen God I say you
must be married to a woman you are not a
sexually attracted to in the Middle East
amen You Ain't Seen Nothing do you see
the flame coming out of TD Jake's butt
and let that Chasm between you and your
wife that unsaid tension
trickle down to your children they know
something's wrong but they don't know
what amen
and that's what Jesus was about when he
said the nuclear family
still holds through it
you're gay you're straight
you don't kiss another man's lips amen
I felt ugly
I felt worthless I felt gay I felt that
no like that you told me I tell you what
man you remember that Freight trip that
you remember covid you remember kovid
covet virus that happened when that
happened when Stephen Crowder
masturbated to gay pornography
I am gay
you must repent and you must condemn the
penis that you so long for we are
straight we are we are straight we are
we are straight
if you think I wouldn't like to touch
and feel
the strong girthiness of a real man's
[__]
of course I would love for that but
Jesus says no
good and so go home and pretend to love
your wife and I feel this
you know Crowder for real you're a freak
dude get back in the closet
disabled
all right thank you for the repenting
everybody
and uh Crowder if you do ever want to
reach out
uh we actually we are very LGBT
Q Plus inclusive everybody's welcome
here and even if you wanted to have a
conversation with me off the record I
can talk to you I mean I'm not gay I'm
not gay
who's gay but I'm I'm well because like
I mean why are you good I I I I can give
him no homo no homo no that's not yeah I
know that's not what I meant though I
know I meant like I'm not a gay man so I
can't help you from that perspective but
I can give you a an open ear yeah an
open heart I think he sometimes that's
all you need right just that's it that's
actually you know what there was a study
about trans kids and there's this really
sad fact that like a huge portion I
think is like 25 or something and that
that may not be right but are like
unaliving themselves and the outcome for
Trans kids when they have just one
older adult figure in their life that
listens to them and accepts them their
outcomes like improved like Yeah by like
90 or something so that's what I want to
be for you Stephen
I just want the best for him that's why
his heart is breaking
you can't carry the weight of loving men
you know
no surprise it's become your family I'm
surprised like Sam Cedar if he calls you
no no
Sam Cedar will not be lying in one way
but you might say you might say that
being bisexual is just liking the
different flavors
flavors all different flavors yeah
some people like mint chocolate some
people like vanilla yeah flavors and
it's not very like different flavors
right
rosebud rosebud is that a flavors I
think that's what Zach puts on the
bathroom that's what I put in my house
yeah
I'm just saying it's just different
flavors
uh can you hit me with the row the
chestnut please
Stephen
Curry
he wants to feel penis
and love it
Stephen Crowder
big fat [__]
and we love that forehead
flavors flavors it's just different
flavors
neighbors layers I told you this episode
would be [__] crazy by the way
speaking of flavors man did I have a
conversation with him this morning oh
really well and camera cam was a witness
so he can he can tell you how [__]
off the rails are tell me everything
um so Jimmy got his Instagram back yeah
and I he thought that uh someone a
restaurant New York
well they thought he was so famous that
they put up a picture of him that's real
it no it's not real no I took one look
at it and it's like oh wait send me the
picture in question you got it Kim uh no
he texted it to you he didn't text you
oh he didn't post it uh here I'll send
it and uh okay so people keep [__]
with Jimmy and sending him these
photoshops yeah that's why Zach that's
why Zach called him to give him a
wellness check to check in to see okay
for a ride here so what what happened
was
um
he he lost his Instagram because he um
thought he could get verified and he
gave his password and [__] to some dude
in Turkey he did that he did he got a
cold DM what he got a cold DM saying
congratulations you've been selected for
a blue check mark oh my God
and I feel really bad his Elder just
gave us your your login yeah by the way
this is really just goes to show you
because I mean look Jimmy he's a bit out
there yeah and he is definitely a senior
citizen but
just look how easy it was to con him and
he was very he was very embarrassed by
it he was you know he was humbled by it
and uh yeah I feel really bad yeah so
did they blackmail him what happened so
he I guess spent like a week trying to
figure it out and I guess he met someone
that really helped him figure it out and
he had to do some type of hacking I
wasn't really sure what he exactly did
but he got it back isn't that why you so
that's why he was off yeah oh yeah
um but was the guy trying to get money
from him like what was the goal there he
didn't mention anything about that uh I
think the guy was just trying to [__]
with him that's awesome um but it sucks
but it's no yeah and I feel really bad
for him but you know I'm like Jimmy do
not trust anyone you meet on the
internet you know except me right
exactly
um trust me right
um but um then the other aspect of this
is
he called me about five times today
repeatedly after one another one another
one another and I'm like Jimmy after
work what do you want you know he's like
oh I want to do a shoot uh this place I
[__] I forget the name of the restaurant
and he's like this is the GM of the
restaurant we need to do it can we do it
and then he I'm like I I don't know I
have to have to figure it out you know
we have to plan it and then he'll call
me again can we do it it'll call me
again can we do it he's relentless
so anyways that's what happened all
right okay thanks for that Jimmy update
um by the way Bing Bong uh thank you for
the gift
says I got my H3 trading cards I love
the one of Alfredo and Shredder oh yeah
I love that one too thank you oh by the
way that reminds me real fast the Elon
Musk shirts are here and there's like I
guess 150 extra yeah if anybody it was
wanting one of those before it sold out
I guess there's there's a
small quantity available uh to anyone
that wants it and this is ready to be
fulfilled right like just search parade
I think would be easiest right now to
find it oh yeah
and so yeah here it is so there's
there's a few
there's a few up there so
if that interests you long math
there it is thank you
um I gotta use the bathroom alrighty
so is this what he thought was real
yes oh my God Jimmy he's like they put
this up in the restaurant for me like
I'm famous Zach I'm [__] famous
so I'm just curious is his does where
does he think his Fame is derived from
like just out there or comedy yeah it's
the street comedy it's finally catching
on yeah and uh he told me that uh send
me a picture of myself so he can put up
on his Instagram because he has all
these new fans and he wants to get my
name out there
well that's gracious of a man to promote
you like that yeah yeah yeah that's
awesome well congratulations Jimmy
obviously uh you're finally being taken
seriously aren't you flavors
just keep trying to yourself dude oh I
was gonna say
um Jimmy if you are watching this
definitely change all your other
passwords because I'm pretty sure all
your passwords are like Jimmy lee123 and
audio audio on you you're going to want
to change those on the other accounts
because he's got them he's got your
password now hold it
for everything
yes talk to your kids man yeah they're
they know what they're doing but this
actually is sad because you know I've
been following the housewives the Jen
Shaw
none of y'all really watching Housewives
it's just me and Ella yeah I was
actually wondering like where I I
started the other day like do I start
with Beverly Hills Beverly Hills oh so
listen I started Salt Lake Salt Lake is
great it's my favorite every season is
great it's also there's not like a
gajillion Seasons like Beverly Hills in
New York have like a billion Seasons I
would start Salt Lake watch it all the
way through I want you with you Lena if
you want to watch at the same time yeah
I'm talking down so right now they're
having to tell all Jen just pleaded
guilty
and it is so [__] good but what
reminds me is that
she's going to prison for basically
conning old people
and you can see via Jimmy just how easy
it is you know it doesn't make you a
mastermind just makes you a [__]
piece of [__] criminal guys
so I guess probably now all these people
who do elder abuse scams are calling
Jimmy they're like yeah I gotta get a
hold of this guy
and he's a mark also he's rich
Jimmy you're playing with fire here bro
he's gonna end up giving out like the
deed to his dental offices to some
hacker from Sri Lanka I mean I I just I
kept reiterating I'm like bro just
please be careful you know because he he
even admitted he's all I'm a [__]
idiot blah blah blah Zach you gotta help
me yeah I just signed over my building
to uh
a man named Tim in Sri Lanka and then
when he did get his Instagram back he
texted me uh probably 10 times in one
day saying I'm bad kid oh period oh kid
oh period like he's Relentless love that
well okay moving on let's see what else
we got Olivia got the meme treatment
from our Guinness World Record
thank you we had um
there was a moment where she was sitting
by herself at the
at the desk actually I need the original
one it's in there yeah so here's the
original one it's pretty funny actually
just kind of like so sad
I didn't know what to do big ass table
by yourself
so people gave her you know here she is
at uh this is the galactic Senate people
have some really really important things
to say that day Hello Olivia here she is
at the
something important yeah yeah
Russian oligarchs yep you're in Putin's
share Vibe yeah it was a good thing a
reflection on the table
whoa Vladimir Putin
um here she is is this Dr Strangelove
yeah that's the War Room the captive uh
of course as always
and so love it oh there's more uh the
Last Supper of Judas right that was Oh
no you're Jesus was she Judas or Jesus
no Jesus is to my uh I left because it
wasn't Judas next to Jesus
I think this might be due to addition
Judas has yeah I think you're just the
oh there's nobody there right no that's
the uh Olivia from the Bible so there
was a Allah there was a ninth disciple
yeah that's that's an addition she's the
secret disciple yeah she was kind of
ditzy that's why they don't talk about
her
what was she all about uh if you recalls
she had a bite she had a whole Bible yes
she she was all about like she was
always drunk all the time that was her
thing I see why she was excluded
you know well edgy
okay
did you talk about Salt Lake City I did
but it's like none of these guys are
awesome yeah Olivia and Lena pledged to
to start watching Salt Lake City
huh
last night we were watching and I was
like we are not worthy I was freaking
out because it was so good it was so
good I was like we are not working this
amazing content we are feasting right
now it's crazy
it's so crazy
oh brother
what's this somebody found an old clip
of me trolling pretty training for his
uh Creator Clash fight oh is this like a
while ago when we knew already four
months ago yeah you hinting me training
for his uh freighter Clash fire why did
you unmatch God help whoever he's up
against
me dead in the eye yeah I just loved
that I love that little inside joke we
had there's a clip go work for the clip
we found it
now there is this one clip
yeah Creator Clash tickets are uh
available or I guess the yeah they're on
sale now the uh
people view BBV bpv tickets
yep
I think it was a lot of sleep last night
Theodore's been Relentless man also the
in-person tickets too eiu and then he
got me
yeah and you are getting out of bed no
because we got to teach him you don't
teach him at 3am I'm not trying to sleep
to the room with me and then she's
playing Hardball with him I'm trying to
sleep because he just woke my ass up
yeah and he's like Mommy come back to
sleep and she's trying to have like
she's like no no no you got to go about
yourself he's like no yeah
he just starts screaming and I'm like
Theodore
and I'm like with my eyes open I can't
once I'm sleeping it's really hard for
me to do the whole waking up that's why
I'm back to sleep
it's really physically hard for me
and I'm just like no screaming and I'm
half asleep
but I like something crazy for a while
so I I walked him back to his room and I
was like I'm gonna wait by the door yeah
not sitting here and he was okay with it
that worked and I waited there for two
minutes and then I walked off oh wow
that's that's actually really good
um
I gotta try that I'm gonna have a
screaming argument with him in the
middle I mean
um also I know y'all are sick and tired
of Andrew Tate but this is so good he's
got he's just suffering and we love to
watch him suffer I'm not debating if
he's a sex trafficker or if women should
exist we're just we're just enjoying his
downfall 50 50. what do we got moose box
set I just finished my sixth session of
ketamine therapy for depression
whoa that's really interesting that
whole
that whole treatment plan what how do
you do that apparently it's like
actually what or what it's documented
that's ketamine
I'm super interested in it helps with
clinical depression
a reaction to ketamine well what they do
I'm pretty sure is they bring in an
actual doctor and a therapist and the
dose that they give you is teeny teeny
tiny and then uh people who have been
dealing with depression and anxiety
forever have said like it's the first
time they've ever felt this way wow like
they've never felt this type of relief
before
it does something apparently and uh well
when I talk to khalila about it sounds
like she was tripping balls doesn't
sound like it was that light of a dose
but I don't know maybe different
experiences were different people like
it made her super high yeah I'm sure it
does
still make YouTube ketamine I think I
think it does I don't know if it's a
psychedelic but you like just trip balls
you're going to like a deep [__]
sleep is it similar to like acid or to
ecstasy like in the I don't think it's I
think it's more like an acid in that you
trip some people have Euphoria on acid
though so I don't know you know I've
never tried ketamine I have smoked crack
once
[__] nice out
but that's a good idea but actually
what's interesting is it actually
there's some clinical results showing
that this works yeah and it's really
used specifically for people who have
like um
like uh let's say clinical
depression that's been resistant to
other treatment methods
um
yeah apparently there's no consensus as
to if ketamine produces can be defined
as psychedelic it sounds psychedelic to
me I'm not really sure yeah it's weird
the way they describe it they it's like
some people say it's like waking up from
Amnesia or Amnesia when they go under
what's that called anesthetic like
waking up from that state but it seems
yeah different different results and
there's a fear right now of that being
addictive for patients I'm saying yeah
cam have you tried it
you are you don't you I mean let's just
save space but you don't have to talk
about it I've had my phone uh yeah
uh ketamine is apparently a super Downer
oh and it feels like a tranquilizer okay
so but yeah so you sit in a in a therapy
office with a
professional and uh
sounds pretty interesting my brother's
girlfriend took a lot of ketamine and
she had a psychotic breakdown okay well
then there's also that well yeah
I don't think you're supposed to like
take it every day yeah
yeah she was already diagnosed with
depression bipolar disorder she hasn't
been the same since well okay that sucks
then there's that I just feel like from
our personal experience like we kind of
tried stuff you know it was never like
using it regularly it was more so like
trying this trying this and I feel like
um I had so many guards up just the way
I grew up and like
I'm talking about like when you take
acid I've just in general in life I had
I was very guarded emotionally person
and I think this kind of stuff really
opened up my oh
I see what your emotions and like being
able to fill different things and so I
think like it was kind of like a
transformative thing for me you're
talking about like the first time we did
like first time we did ecstasy or MDMA
whatever you or first time we did acid
you know the first time so Ela came
how long had you been there you just it
was like our first you just moved there
right night or something did you was
that during
your six month State yeah that was
during your six months stay
yes and Ila was staying with me
and I got this idea that we should do
maybe not our first night but it was
like a week or something yeah
I got this idea that we should do
um
e together
I was young I don't know what how good
of an idea it was but it I guess my
theory at the time I'm a dumb I'm a
young dumb idiot you know so we're about
very young yeah so this I'm not saying
this is a good thing for you to do
this is what I think everything in
moderation and responsibility is okay
well I was thinking like you know we
haven't seen each other in a while and I
feel like it would really open us up
and have us connect and Eli had never
actually even tried I've never done
anything anything up to that except like
alcohol and cigarettes
right and so we went on like we were in
Santa Cruz and we went on like this
crazy wild goose chase we had to drive
up to San Francisco right one I forget
who who gave me the contact but we drove
up all the way to San Francisco
to buy two pills yeah and we came down
and you know sometimes it's good
sometimes it's good and sometimes it's
not that good and this happened to be
the best [__] it was like ever dude
they were insane like that was the best
way ecstasy I've ever had
a little bit more tell me a little bit
more yeah so we we just had like
night like we were just listening to
music talking and sitting outside
looking at the sky like just like oh my
God it was beautiful and that's the only
time you've ever done it ecstasy yes and
then we did later on a few times MDMA
right like I could count it on one hand
not when I say a few times like three
yeah over the years over the years yeah
once a year when we were in yeah
and um
but yeah we got lucky because we could
have gotten anything I didn't know who
we're buying it from but I think that it
really was like a big thing for me
because I
this was coming off of living with my
parents
pretty difficult like Dad yeah and
the Army and like just like really high
intensity situations
and never had done anything like that
and it was just like super
eye-opening and like
it's like a range of emotions that you
don't think you can experience it's
weird and it's like it was great and so
I just feel like I could really see
drugs helping therapy but obviously I
don't want to sound like a hippie well
they're using they're using MDMA which
is the active drug and ecstasy ecstasy
is like just when it comes in the people
think MDMA is just the crystals ecstasy
is when it's like in a pill and it's
usually cut with something else like
caffeine or something no no no not speed
in the field no I don't know I don't
think it's supposed to be cut with speed
I don't know
I thought that twice I thought that
that's like I don't know I have no idea
no no no
I think it was just yeah
and so
yeah we took and what was it crazy is
that how much you trusted me to try
because you had never done anything and
let's be real ecstasy is a pretty
I think the whole thing really shows how
much I trusted you because I like came
all the way to America just to be with
you and also my brother drove me up to
you and like the whole time he was like
are you sure like who is this guy's
doing
but we spent like every day on Skype for
at that point was it a year or two years
a year yeah a year or two I don't even
remember and so it was like hours and
hours of talking and I just felt like I
knew you so well I wasn't even a
question in my mind of like can I trust
you or not people are saying they are
co-signing your yes it was cut with
speed
I think that's what I heard because in
in apparently that's why mdme MDMA is
like the pure but in the pill they put
all kinds of crap I totally get being a
meth head now because that's just
slapped
um
so anyway it was like just an awesome
night and uh yeah it was it was there
you go wrong
and it really brought us together really
fast it was kind of crazy how it worked
out and Ela was up for it which was
crazy and but yeah you know they're
they're also studying using
MDMA and therapy sessions too with
people with uh I think that's
post-traumatic stress yes I think that's
really good I really do same with um
psilocybin mushrooms as well they're
doing oh that's so interesting
there it is but yeah I'm not I'm not
encouraging but again this is all drugs
this is an anecdotal experience you know
it it really can be unsafe I just want
to give it I think it's I see it more as
like a once in a lifetime thing worth
trying
yeah well again nowadays I wouldn't
never because I have to work I have to
be present for the kids I have so many
things going I literally don't do
anything other than drink coffee yeah
but um I'm just saying like be
responsible I'm not saying that it's
going to be the same for you I am not
telling you to do any drugs okay I'm not
I don't want to encourage anyone to do
that
so that's it and get it from someone you
trust if you do do it unlike us but it
was a [__] ruled I was a friend of a
friend so I did trust them I do it with
everyone okay
H3 H3 and dust industry said Thank you
for allowing us to create clip channels
I hope I can build something over time
that makes you proud oh well I hope so
God that you said that I think that's a
great idea wait what's this channel is
he is they already getting to work h3h3
industry I love that yeah we opened up
our CL our IP to anyone who wants to
make Clips page three eight yeah each
three here is H3 industry hard at work
with two videos two subscribers
let's go get in there
a b fights a security guard not click
bait and Prince Harry oscillates what
pretty good titles those are good you
approve
ment
um Good Start Good Start I told you
smoker my willy Wally
have you heard the prince oh I just to
go back to that other subject for a real
quick what we were talking about was
years ago at this point oh decades ago
somebody was saying so many things are
laced with fentanyl today oh this one I
have heard about that and that is really
scary why are they doing it I don't know
why are they doing that I don't think
fentanyl is like cheap where it's like
economical it's cheaper when I yeah when
I worked at the needle exchange and
people would cut the drugs with more
fentanyl obviously they would mm-hmm
have a crazy effect people would die but
also like some people would develop
crazy boils and stuff so what's the goal
of doing that just so people still get
high so they don't think they're ripped
off like I don't get it
like why not just put baby powder or
some [__] or like flour well
um I guess for the effects of it I know
because Fentanyl
gets you way higher than op or like the
pills yeah so it's or it's just
intensified like times a million okay
that's [__] crazy yeah this I'm when
this happened that when did I graduate
from college this was debt literally
decades ago I was probably like 20
five or something
no this was
it no you were younger than that
10 years ago no that was younger than
that
how old was I 23 maybe 23. that was 12
years ago
[Music]
somehow it feels longer further away
than that yeah
because
there it is maybe 14 years ago well [__]
I'm not even Street saving with all this
fentanyl [__] so
maybe I won't even be [__] around
with it if it was all that crazy out
there and I don't know if there's ways
to test your drugs today
I'll also say this
just to give a balanced a report the
worst I've ever felt or one of the worst
times I've ever felt is when we did
this acid and MD and it was just [__]
horrid dude it was just awful God it
felt so bad the next day and the high
wasn't that good it was just [__]
terrible
so you know what I mean
there it is
all right so let's tap let's just
[__] spit on Andrew Tate's grave here
take a big piss on it
check this out my money that is why I'm
in jail I have money that they were
trying to steal
snoozers
is this the Matrix fault
there's no justice in Romania
unfortunately did you hurt anything so
hold on what did you saying he says
there's no justice in Romania they're
gesturing arresting us because they want
our money but then if you go back
a few years ago he he moved to Romania
explicitly because there are no rules
here when I moved to Romania because in
Eastern Europe none of this garbage
flies if you don't know the police and
say he raped me back in 1988 because we
should have done something about it then
if you order please stay right in
yesterday say okay if you've got
physical evidence or is there CCV proof
okay let's go interview him right now
well there's there there is a clip of
him saying somewhere that he
he can just pay off the police he goes
into the police station with the stack
of money yeah yeah we saw that too
there's a clip go look for the clip and
now he's complaining that they're
corrupt it's just it's beautiful it's
not it's just beautiful
is it in this one too is this like a
compilation let me see no it's not a
compilation
this is so good I'm loving I just want
to watch it again well I'm in jail I
have money that they were trying to
steal
nothing wrong they know we've done
nothing wrong with The Matrix
beautiful I'm so glad people are asking
about the Matrix
so [__] awesome
the case
there's no justice in Romania
did you hurt any girl
of course that is why I'm in jail I have
money that they were trying to steal
shut up dork
yeah what's funny about this video too
is you can see his like botched hair
transplant which is why he you know he
shaves his head how did the two brothers
are like so messed up together they're
in it you know like I don't know I feel
like siblings like each one goes in a
completely different direction well they
have Daddy Issues their dad was like an
absent father and Tristan being the
younger brother probably just latched on
to Tate you know became his Lackey
apparently they have a sister too that's
like normal really yeah he's like I
don't talk to that [__] he's like she's
just you know she doesn't get it like
she's like a normal person I feel bad
for her yeah that's wild isn't it yeah
check out this photo of uh our dearly
beloved
Andrew Tate
you know and let's not talk let's just
not talk about high value males
now
does being in prison how does that
affect your value as a male is that it's
in the [__] probably a negative yeah
right let's not talk about making money
okay and
the hairline
as the hairline King
I do believe I'm in a position to say is
this is this a high value uh male
hairline
and I don't want to be judgmental right
right but at the same time I'm just
using his words I think that there are
bald Kings like then
proud
King proud Warriors this uh-uh
because this is like he's not accepting
who he is right
[Music]
you're holding on to what
my my [__] ass has thicker hair than
that
[Music]
did I I'm so happy we like appropriated
keemstar sound
no I didn't know that he had this dumb
[__] sound effect and it's just one
sound effect and he hits it every time
and we stole oh my God yeah we stole it
we found out it's a stock sound from
some like mixing board oh you left yeah
someone messaged us okay oh it's a stalk
sound
so you got the clean you got the clean
original version is that good good nice
[Music]
but yeah he's not accepting who like a
high value male is confident accepts who
they are
go ahead with the sad music please
just not slurping over open flyer
that's not actually the one but yeah
you know
he did well to be fair he was shaving it
bald
before he got arrested too bad he got
arrested that's where he [__] up
it is what it is yeah you didn't look
too good though it's a shame dead
dinosaurs we're almost seeing like a
Harvey Weinstein uh degrading already
like he's falling apart he's been to the
hospital for his lungs it's like dude
yeah apparently that's what that's what
I've been hearing recorded
I have small dick energy
and actually if you pull up a picture of
Harvey Weinstein in prison there is this
they look similar there is something
going on there
really yeah man
it's because he he ain't getting his
doses of
baby blood what do you call that what do
you call that [__] yeah he's not getting
his adrenal Chrome
I'd rather [__] dudes
yeah let me see here let me put a
picture of Harvey plowed
hold on
I'm just playing a picture of Harvey
Weinstein just for comparison here I
think there's something interesting to
be said about this
so as you can see
there is a resemblance from when Harvey
Weinstein was in jail and he really aged
poorly
you know look at look at how [__] up
he is his eyes are on different planes
this one's ways too low this one's high
it's unattractive
oh wait this isn't Harvey Weinstein oh
who is this
a dick Ryan Kavanaugh
Rosetta had one serial killer
I can't remember
bro what is this what the [__] is this
cam
what I didn't love dropped that I don't
know is this an AI generated yeah if you
were sent it to me oh my God
it's pretty funny
he sure is
by the way this is
a fake image
okay I mean he he has kissed him though
like there's pictures of him kissing him
so it's not that far cry of a
there's a whole album if you want to see
more I would love to yeah no I would
love to I mean we just have to say these
are not real images they're created by
AI
and in fact I didn't even create them so
suck it
but here yeah you can see the
resemblance I mean they're aging kind of
like
Andrew was just like a few weeks away
from being like this at this rate
do you see it I sure do
thank you I'm gonna make that my phone
wallpaper
so wait we have a whole album of those
yeah it's I just linked it and then just
give you a big
um I don't see it
oh this here thank you all right let's
take a look the magical adventures of
Ron Kavanaugh
mid-journey parody
okay so this is Ron Kavanaugh
oh is his face always hidden
I love how embracing and loving they are
wow both in prison together talking shop
Ron Kavanaugh
they look the same bro what the hell
even this AI knows they look the same
this is so insane these two men these
are the same people
you know
I love this this is your best friends
these two are inseparable what is this
movie dude his fingers are so [__]
crazy
I don't know if you know this but Ai and
all of its infinite capabilities can't
do hands
last I heard they couldn't do faces but
not now I'm impressed the faces they got
down yeah
these two guys are just homies man
oh wait what is this one that's Natalie
Portman
this is Ron having an affair with
underage Natasha support noise
I don't think she's allowed in a bar at
that just so you know relationship by
the 40 year old definitely you know Ron
explaining his business structure to a
new Hollywood studio
that of course is in the shape of a
pyramid
but she was accused of running by his
partner but it was later retracted so
it's worth mentioning that it was
retracted oh it's just a triangle it
yeah totally food pyramid
this is him dude he's looking good too
much wine
looks like this guy got drunk on wine
just went for a really terrible choice
to go joyriding driving when did he turn
into like an action hero what the hell
laughs
first hand experience dude what the [__]
so there it is these are all AI
generated none of these are reels
bite me with peace and love thank you
Tasman devil for those thank you Jasmine
devil
all right what else we got
everybody keeps asking in the chat about
Jay Leno oh yeah we should talk about
poor Jay Leno
my God I'm so gutted about poor Jay Leno
he's back in the hospital what is going
on turned off yeah playing with rocket
fuel or some [__]
and now as I read this can you please um
set the the tone please
yeah we're just going to roll some
b-roll here as I explain what happened
yeah so in an interview with Los Las
Vegas uh review journal
Leno revealed that he's recovering from
another recent motorcycle accident that
left him with several broken bones
only months after he sustained second
degree burns I mean the world is trying
to tell you something
okay I think so and you should have got
the message the first time right man in
this video
as you guys remember back in November
Jay was working on a clogged fuel line
and the undercarriage of his 1907 White
Steam
this time he was on the road testing a
vintage 1940 Indian
motorcycle
I don't know that he can keep doing this
stuff he's gonna die Jay
when he noticed the scent of leaking gas
and decided to pull over to investigate
this man keeps getting burned by
gasoline it's all this vintage stuff
it's not safe be blown up by gasoline
twice in like a three months span
yeah go you could play it again because
there's more to read yeah
he said so I turned down the side street
cut through a parking lot and
unbeknownst to me some guy had a wire
strung across the parking lot but with
no flag hanging from it so you know I
didn't see it until it was too late it
closed the line to me and boom knocked
me off the bike the bike kept going and
you know how that works out wait what
does he have a family
yeah yeah he does yeah
this man got someone
yes stop okay go golfing like other
[__] Rich fat white guys
there's other Hobbies does it hit Jay
Leno's life his final destination bro
he's supposed to die
he needs to die for the universe to be
right
dude he got clotheslined what
yeah so uh Leno is set to start playing
in Las Vegas in early March if you
survived still then I'm sure he's gonna
have another oh he doesn't have kids
no just a wife oh so there's nothing to
live for no I'm just kidding sorry what
people get mad yeah no I'm just kidding
oh God just kidding
[Music]
Jay Leno let me see Jay lano's wife
let's see this poor woman who is
who is on the edge of her seat every day
look what you're putting her through Jay
what are you putting her through
knock it over my wife Jay stop it let
her live a life of Peace man
why are you worried about my wife
I just want the best for her Jay that's
all
okay
thank you
foreign
[Music]
yes it was a brutal fall it was a brutal
crash that day my friends
they never stopped rolling
they say the car's still rolling today
thank you Zach
appreciate that buddy
be the greatest thing I've ever seen man
thank you man oh my God I'm proud of
that I don't know how much is left it
makes that
um
crying it was fun yeah it was fun by the
way somebody made a matrix animation of
me talking to Aiden this is kind of oh
my God that's Urgent Message for Aiden
Ross if you know Aiden Ross please make
sure he sees this video
most people are missing the true story
here do you understand
The Matrix is after you ate it wrong and
this is why I'm making this urgent
urgent message to you you thought that
Hancock tape is gonna be your Neo but I
have a bad news for you Angie Tate is
actually going to be your agent Smith
I'm more beautiful bro this is the
matrix it's real wake up take my hands
[Music]
it took me a while to understand that
and you know it did
and I I just want to say bro okay I'm
ready bro
[Music]
I love it yeah thank you love it
beautiful thank you too
Oni blue
appreciate that nice times all right
what do you guys want to talk about we
have David responds to Jeff's newest eye
surgery which was actually pretty juicy
another like psycho [__] David thing
or mascara gate love or
we already talked about poor Jay Leno
okay dork brags about young people why
young people are before this guy's a
[__] creep dumbass we'll get to him
maybe we also have Austin Butler
PowerPoint T presented I think that and
the eyelash
and dubrick
yes let's do a poll yeah do a poll yeah
let's do a pull we'll pick the top three
they do and if we have time we'll do
more obviously but
you know
dubrick oh as you're setting that up I
got uh Shredder's blood test yeah
so there's four markers
three of them were significantly better
the main one which is the main marker
for kidney disease is creatine right
that one went down a very small amount
0.1 yeah
so like if it was 3.5 3.4 or something
yeah that's exactly what it was
and so I was like I mean I'm it's not
worse so I'm happy and he again
the normal range was way above yeah on
Creatine he's in stage three kidney
failure at that rate
so
she says she considers it progress
because the other three went down so
much so we're just gonna keep you know
course forward and hoping that the
creatine levels continue I feel really
positive though and Ethan every time I
feel positive is get scared but I just
feel like we see him and he looks he
looks better than ever like than we
remember him in a long time
super energized and like he's eating his
kibble food which is unheard of
so I think he just ate yeah it's unheard
of so I think overall he's doing really
good so I agree his attitude his uh mood
his Play Levels he's been he's like
better than he's been in years yeah I
think he was just on a diet that was
really bad for him definitely we didn't
know
and so that's awesome I'm just I just
get scared when I get I I need to hedge
my expectations otherwise I'm just going
to be
devastated and I'm afraid that one day
we're going to get that blood test and
the creatine levels are going to be
going up or flat I really need those
levels going down
it's not good if it doesn't
but he's doing great and I'm just being
guarded but I'm very I'm very happy that
even we have this time where he's
healthy and happy together it's been
amazing it has been yeah
wait you only did three options
we only said three
anyway
bad ball dude welcome to bad policy
David dobrik is winning though first
time here oh is it really well that
won't go fast
we what I was saying we have time for
all three of these okay so let's do them
all right let's do dubro
yeah Jeff who's coming on the show on
Wednesday
just had another operation this poor guy
yeah how long ago was that and this poor
guy is still
getting surgeries in his [__] eye
like it looks like a serious surgery I
can't imagine having to like the eye
that's such a sensitive
another one down thank you for all the
love and support thank you Dr Cook
thank you pain meds yes
so
obviously we wish Jeff the best he's a
bestie a friend of the show
it's been three years since that
happened he's still suffering from it
well the same day that Jeff posted that
yeah now if you remember
there was David had previously done
something like this when the sculpture
with the scope the giant sculpture of
the eye yeah and so at the time we're
like is this for is he trying to say
something and obviously there was like
uh a lot of plausible deniability there
for him could you have a picture of that
one yeah give me one sec
but now that it's happened again so
what's happened this time
let me show you the original photo of
jog your guys's memory okay
so what happened this time
H3 clips that make me smile sending love
oh I forgot to say
um happy birthday
to the one and only
uh Marina Martini burrito
[Applause]
I saw someone asked if they could clip
members content yes and it's a no right
they can yes so yes they can clip
members content yeah definitely
right
so here's what he posted oh you gave it
similarly so here's what he did last
time
and we even asked Jeff about it and he's
like you know I'm just trying not to
think about it
and I think it was the same day he had a
surgery too now this artist does like
her thing is like IR yeah but if you're
like known for like
punt we're destroying people's vision
and tearing out people's eyes it's a
little psycho to put that up
but okay let's see what he did this time
okay
so the same day
wait what the [__] is this
this was a thumbnailing from November
is this another uh alleged Jeff Jab
people were talking about it yeah
it's a lot of eye content
so it is kind of curious
but Jeff seems pretty convinced that
this newest one was was intentional so
yeah here let's open it up
he posted with his friends who have all
turned on Jeff
and they said we don't give a [__]
and it was the same right after Jeff
posted his picture
and these are all his [__] fake
friends who've left him what's their
names this is Todd and that's Zayn and
Zane
it was interesting that it wasn't posted
from Todd's main account I mean
obviously it is still his because he
commented on it but yeah I think that
makes it even more
responsibilities mean they wanted him to
see it yeah
we don't give a [__] what do you mean
who's the comment posted this account is
his like second account and I wonder if
he thought that's like a more private
one I don't know but Jeff follows it
everyone follows it
um
let's see there's more photos they're
celebrating they're drinking
They're laughing this right after Jeff
posted the picture of his eye
yeah we don't give a [__]
Outback Steakhouse that sounds good
blooming onions
stay on topic and so oh Outback
I agree that this is
um gross more than the eye sculpture
because
it could be that he just really liked
the art yeah and she's possible yeah
it's possible but there's just now too
much
and and obviously
um Jeff is like told this is what Jeff
told me David's telling everybody don't
you can't talk to him you can associate
with him apparently even Jonah the guy
who Jeff used to make content with was
cut off like it's a [__] cult like he
actually Cuts people off yeah and now
that Jeff's suing David I think it's
just
um yeah
his way of getting back yeah so check
this out there's absolutely no way this
was just a coincidence a pick with David
one hour apart yeah
and then he posted Jeff posted this he
said this was just brought to my
attention thanks for spelling yourself
you scumbags I wish I knew this
how y'all felt when I kept my mouth shut
to try to protect this piece of [__] put
down the booze and get to litigation
yeah I hope you yeah man I'm ruined for
him so I have a question is that post
still up with the same caption
yes okay so it's definitely on purpose
because it could have been let's say
it's accident but then somebody pointed
it out to them I'm sure a lot of people
if they erased it would probably mean
that they they're like oh okay this is
not okay but if they left it up they're
like yeah he commented on it actually if
you scroll down a little bit he says
haha Jesus this isn't about Jeff and I
haven't deleted comments I'm having fun
with my friends goddamn
oh yeah no no I know I'm just no I I
appreciate that I'm not I'm not yeah
Jeff then came out he said it's all good
I'll tell the real story soon but I'm a
little tired right now so I need to go
to sleep when I wake up I'm going Defcon
3.
or whatever's left of that fake group of
friends and I don't think he has it gone
Defcon 3 yet has he
not to my knowledge he didn't get he
really has ammunition left in the
chamber
after all he's after all they've been
through now what
so what do you mean he's officially
suing right yes that's happening so yeah
him going Defcon 3 may not be in a
public way that we're thinking
when I wake up I'm going Defcon 3. well
last time on Wednesday
maybe he got some pointers from Kanye
about going Defcon 3.
but what do you guys think let's do a
poll you think David is doing this
intentionally or it's just a coincidence
curious what the people think
you know
let's throw it up
chestnuts
Jeff's eye blooping in the blood
excavator spinning with bad cadavers
eyeballs popping out of sockets
[Music]
uh we are working on a new pole okay
Ethan
Jeff I'm on your side on this one Jeff
Khan Ethan Jeff Jeff gone
okay Ethan oh wow yeah it's a blowout
people really think this is intentional
it's gonna be hard to get away from that
there's just like too much coincidence
um
there's no such thing as a coincidence
and I think that kind of just wraps it
up right there so that's the uh that's
the T sis yeah take it from me and uh we
are all rooting for Jeff I hope that he
gets a beautiful eye at the end of this
with great vision
okay and he can see everything
clearly now that the rain is gone
uh
yeah hold on one sec uh I'm hoping that
what the [__] is that
uh they're doing some work on the roof I
believe
until the rain was gone that was rain
Jeff hopefully you can see clearly uh
when the rain is gone and he can see all
the obstacles in his way
and uh now that the dark clouds that had
blinded him are going to be gone
it's going to be bright for him
and I think when his eyes fix he's going
to have a really sunny day
yeah and when his eyes fixed the pain is
going to go away hmm all the bad
feelings will disappear
and uh he's gonna see a rainbow
and I hope he wins his lawsuit too after
all that too yeah yeah it's gonna be a
bright bright sunny day
that was that was gorgeous man the look
around look all around there's nothing
but blue skies James Joyce here right
there thank you yeah look straight ahead
there's nothing but blue skies for Jeff
it's you know Oscar Wilde Worthy
I can see clearly now the rain is gone
said Jeff
I can see all the obstacles in my way
there's the rainbow I've been praying
for
it's gonna be a bright bright
it's going to be a bright bright
sunshiny day got it thank you
thank you thank you thank you a little
performance art for you guys
foreign
so that's it that's all we got on Jeff
but we wish him well we'll see him on
Wednesday eh yep I really want to see
your uh your
PowerPoint
Olivia because I am so
interested in Austin Butler the guy who
played Elvis yes his [__] voice he
didn't go back to his normal voice he's
still just walking around talking like
Elvis all right guys it's so cringy dude
it's so weird oh thank you very much
this is just my voice now Austin Butler
so let's show us the show us the
receipts do you want to do the reading
and then or here I'll open it yeah
so this is an original PowerPoint by
Olivia
Olivia Olivia Hello Olivia
thank you now if you Austin Butler and
when is it time to stop talking hmm
here he is Golden Globe winner 2022 for
his depiction of Elvis of course best
actor
how can I say something I didn't I don't
know why
I have disliked him from the minute I
laid off his face annoys me and I don't
know if anyone can relate but I don't
know how to I don't even know how to
explain it but something about perfect
personal thing that you it reminds me of
it reminds you of somebody you don't
feel that
when I look at him I'm like this dude is
so [__] smug and self that that is
that is one thing that I see it's like
he is so like he thinks he's so good
looking like you can tell
he's so oh thank you sweetie yeah
growing when I was growing up watching
TV he always was the guest star of like
a hot guy that's always what he's played
oh okay I uh I like him because he's
Goss adjacent Jesus bro oh and God [__]
yeah he's got the Goss Vibe no well I'm
not saying he's the Goss I'm just saying
you even making that comparison he's a
good looking dude
yeah
I gotta just there's no shot wait I'm
not singing I don't think I'm in the
same sentence I'm saying he's humble you
know what I mean who is God Gosling wait
Ian are you anti-butler
[Music]
I'm just saying he's adjacent he's new
to the block give him a shot I don't
like
I don't like him but you do whatever you
want with your male fantasies and I like
his voice I don't think there's anything
wrong like his voice really you don't
think it's cringy that he did Elvis now
he's walking out oh thank you very much
dude he played [__] Elvis yes he's
not Elvis though like did he forget did
he he knows that he was acting right
he's not Elvis he's still method what
about Elvis too you know oh oh Zach I
don't know what you're talking about
here this is just how I sound baby now
come on shake that thing for me I don't
hate it I don't hate it that's [__]
weird that's weird I hate it so much
don't hate it well then you're his
you're his Target demo
I find his face so pretentious like I
can't deal with it but okay okay let's
get let's continue on we're already
getting caught up
listen to Austin's acceptance speech
okay here it is
wait
oh it doesn't it doesn't look clickable
when I click it goes to the next one
okay thank you
okay listen to this [__]
that is acceptance speech and by the way
you're gonna be maybe he's just doing
[__] for the acceptance no he's doing
this everywhere
off stage
[Applause]
oh my words are leaving stop stop stop
and said just to play the
just to hear his his uh
okay okay did it did it message pop up
no no no no it did when I put it in on
Mondays all right so okay got it so
let's just play I just I'm so grateful
right now I'm in this room full of my
heroes Brad I love you that's great
printed out the Pulp Fiction Street
I cannot believe I'm here right now
there's more videos
before boys I want to also say to my
fellow nominees oh my God
hold on hold on hold on this man goes I
want to say to all of my fellow nominees
he's talking like old-timey yeah he's
like okay Your Voice Change also you're
talking old-timey now like what does
that mean
bro that's so crazy this is unacceptable
I don't hate it I don't hate it this is
Ultimate Korean yeah it's you know I'll
die on this [__] Hill I don't hate it
don't die Zach come on Tech I'm talking
oh Timmy look it makes no sense he just
played Elvis I think he could be [__]
cocky and he did it well too
oh this is so [__] overrated bro
I don't even okay that's here nor there
but Elvis the Elvis the Elvis hype is so
overrated okay I will agree with that
somewhat so then what do you okay but
I'm just saying as an iconic figure come
on Elvis like is there anyone more
iconic oh thank you ever I want to say
thank you
but Monies
all right let's keep going I'm shocked
yeah
and I am so honored and proud to be
listed among you yeah I owe this it's
like he's doing a 90 year old impression
Visionary you ain't nothing but a hound
dog baby
allowed me the experience to test this
is crazy and I always knew I would be
supported baz Lerman I love you I love
you
thank you for believing in me in those
moments that I didn't even believe in
myself I'm so grateful to you to you I
also want to thank my dance partner the
greatest dance party
Tom Hanks thank you thank you
Washington Denzel thank you baby thank
you for your generosity generosity when
you did not have to how do you explain
that he goes generosity
I want to thank you baby everyone in
there I guarantee is like what is going
on right now come on now they're like go
off King Zach I was willing to give him
a chance I was very neutral but this guy
does not [__] after here okay that's
fine yeah whatever I like that you're
sticking with him but man come on Zach I
think you know the dude studly he can do
what he wants come on baby I agree with
Zach oh maybe he doesn't bear his accent
yeah thank you
well like a lot of people tell me I have
an accent I'm like what I don't know no
no no no no but that's your accent no
you know okay
he probably doesn't hear it anymore
there's three boys
but he's been doing that voice for so
long like how long is he on to do to
deliver a performance like that I'm sure
he likes practice no it had to be longer
it was three years he was doing it for
three years they were filming for three
years yeah in Australia why doesn't take
that long to film I could have done that
in three months
like I know production goes for a while
Dan would know but I thought no there's
no way they were recording for three
years you know they didn't shoot
Apocalypse Now in three years and I was
like well not just shooting even but no
I mean yeah he got the role
three years
he's trying to Hype him he could have
got the role I've been practicing for
three years yes like I understand
production takes a long time yeah but
when you're actually on set shooting
that's like three months Tops on a big
movie now come on baby it's very
expensive now I've been on shooting this
character for three months I I think I'm
Elvis
I'm a little old hound dog named Elvis
but it's nothing like you having an
accent yeah his quotes about it not
changed your voice well but if I let's
say I was going to be doing a role where
I did have to address the way I spoke
and stuff who knows maybe I would end up
sticking with that afterwards if I'm
just so used to it and then I just
couldn't tell the difference anymore
come on Elena who are you kidding now
come on over here you go any 16 year
olds looking to get married come on
my hound dog now
another thing is I just don't think it's
that good of an impersonation to be
honest I don't mean to hate I think he
did a good job in the movie but I'm not
hearing Elvis like I I'm hearing someone
do Elvis it's
yeah I agree it's great all right like
Elvis I feel is more like it's more
quicker bounce to what he's saying
I don't know it's just country to me all
right let me see that proves he's not
trying to speak like Elvis
we don't have enough information yet we
have we have to keep investigating
so grateful for all I'm so grateful
I also want to thank our incredible
producers are incredible and the Presley
family oh my God they're playing his ass
off your your members
okay what's the bit please
this is just who I am you could at least
play suspicious minds or something
um
um all right enough for you
bottom line is you want there's a Golden
Globe right
that's all you want a Golden Globe and
he's probably gonna win a [__] Oscar
so it's like who cares no he's not
I think he'll win who cares delusional
who cares he's going to Oscar who cares
he's just Deep In His Voice come on baby
so people can talk [__] but he's the one
laughing oh my God but he said he sounds
like Bill Clinton
I was thinking the same thing no I
didn't I did not have sex relationship
with that 16 year old like Howard always
does blank Bill Clinton yeah
impersonation that's what this sounds
like to me come on
yeah Hillary
now listen you might see Monica Lewinsky
coming out this office hey Monica I just
I want you to look the other way
let's talk about what we know okay
Austin Butler's hot okay
we know that we know that so this is an
established fact okay all right okay
Austin Butler played Elvis these are in
these are right okay uncontested facts
given circumstances Austin Butler just
won a Golden Globe okay
okay so why does he talk like that
Austin Butler's from Anaheim California
next to Disneyland Lena
this man grew up in Los Angeles ain't
nobody here talking like this maybe he
just went on uh Big Thunder a lot you
know love Big Thunder Mountain like that
guy that talks right before the ride
Southern Big Thunder no I definitely
think he's still talking like Elvis I'm
just saying I don't think he hears it
himself or that it's intentional come on
I think that's
him I think it's impossible too it could
be I appreciate you're the grace you're
giving him like Graceland baby where I
walk
I mean I'm sure that everybody deserves
a little Grace yeah three and some 16
year old
you know he married a 16 year old come
on baby it's always um Love Is Love it's
always surprising when like there's
actors who will have like uh in real
life that'll have English accent but
then in a show or a movie they play
without it but you you never see it like
going away when they're out of character
they're fully right back in their you
know
mother language I mean yeah you see lots
of crazy method acting like uh Daniel
Day Lewis doesn't walk around like uh
has Abraham Lincoln know
but Elvis is like such a
and let's say he didn't put that much
practice and effort into it
right now we'd be criticizing him for
not doing a good job as Elvis so maybe
like this consequence is is better than
better than that hey hey you know what
my surprise to see the the Elvis Presley
Good in everyone yeah here here's
something good about me
I used to sleep with 14 year olds when I
was on tour come on
yeah
[Music]
um
who watched that movie here was that in
the movie The obviously they're actually
they there was a point where they met
when he went overseas to war was it a
child Oh you mean Priscilla yeah she was
14 when they met yeah baby that's how
like that and her dad had some
involvement was in the Army yeah
according to the book about I used to
have pillow fights people wrestling kiss
14. a number of young girls that would
befriend
yes sir the only slack I'm willing to
give Austin is maybe it made his voice
deeper because he spoke like that for a
long time I think that that would be a
fair like oh wow his voice like shifted
down a few octaves not oh wow he's from
Texas that's just not how it works
I'm seeing the film wrapped in March of
2021 and the Golden Globes were in
January of 2022. decompress
yeah Elvis has left the building at that
point yeah thank you and by the way so
he's from Anaheim I was asking did
anyone here watch the movie yeah you
guys really watched it good yeah I liked
it I mean
there's a lot to cover in such a short
amount of time but it focused more on
his manager um which Tom Hanks played it
was amazing by the way okay yeah he was
a [__]
freaked I would have liked to have seen
Elvis on the toilet dying but you know
you can only get with you know can't get
everything
I would have liked to see more of his
come up and like his glory days because
I feel like they focused a lot which is
not a bad thing but just on um how he
was like how the industry treated him
and his manager and kind of like took
advantage of his talent hey Lena you
know why they didn't focus on my early
days because I was [__] 14 year old
girl that's why come on that's why
Lena's defending him she was crying in
the watching the movie maybe that's why
the last scene when he's singing his
heart out I mean it's [__] no it was
it was sad
you know what's sad
taking a 14 year old's girl virginity
come on baby
the fans have continuously pointed out
that Austin's voice
has been different ever since shooting
Elvis here is an example showcasing his
voice before and after so here wait oh
here okay got it thank you
wait hold on
I click this okay move across town and I
was really late to the meeting but they
waited and so I was kind of the only
person there so it just all the stars
felt like they were aligning even even
though I was late night I hate being
late it was like it felt special it was
kind of I didn't expect that he would
feel that type of fear and uh and so
that was really liberating for me to
know that I hear no different pressure
that I was here come on come on Zach you
don't hear like a regular guy and then
Bill Clinton no I just hear a dude from
the OC
right responsibility and the fear that I
have is okay you know so so because he
was feeling I I hadn't read the books
beforehand when I first when I first met
with with the guys
um with Alan miles and Jonathan our
director
um
come on now
I don't sell nothing like that kid I
just hadn't hit puberty yet
you know
your impressions kind of sounded like a
mix between um
Bill Clinton like Barry White he's just
been buried by the way I hear the rest
Zach [__] put me on that cross baby
I'm here you're underground you're not
on the cross
whatever any comment so there it is I
had three years where that was my only
focus so I'm sure there's a piece of him
in my DNA and I'll always be like no
baby that's not how that works be it in
your DNA you're just a weirdo and you
lack something like this think you think
it makes you look hot and cute yes
but you sound really embarrassing and
he's handsome and hot so nobody ever
correct him
our DNA history what is that term
all the littles all the little girlies
love me like Zach they talk to me like
Zach yep
they say I can't hear a difference
same as before and after might go catch
some waves with the dude from the Orange
County that's right
okay there it is I love that story
oh okay was there more oh yeah all the
girlfriends you just poured the tea you
haven't even yeah you haven't even
sipped it I thought that was it for some
reason
so let's go ahead
um come on now
okay
from Anaheim we got any comment
yeah we got that one with all the
discourse surrounding it you would think
Butler would be more aware of his
vernacular but his Golden Globes
acceptance speech was Dripping with
Elvis in fact some are speculating
Butler chose to accept the ward and his
Elvis voice purposely
I would have been hilarious if Austin
Butler Switched Off the Elvis wise mid
speech
Austin Butler putting on Elvis voice
whenever he feels like it Austin Butler
has one more chance to shut the Elvis
voice off I swear to God
okay now who's gonna award Austin Butler
an exorcist to get this Elvis voice out
of him
have we checked on the hypnotist that's
holding Austin Butler in a Perpetual
Elvis voice trance
but how did we get here Alfredo just
wandered off yes he's up to note by uh
cam Austin Butler was cast as Elvis
let's go back in time
Austin Butler's dating uh history
Vanessa
Hudgens
Hudgens she I don't I think I'm too old
that I missed this whole she was in high
school musical okay okay and they've
dated they dated for like 10 years
10 years okay
she was a little too old for me uh
I lock him a little younger than that 14
sounds good
Vanessa encouraged us to seek out a
project to play Elvis
um interesting before the Elvis biopic
was announced she campaigned for him to
play Elvis
then
Splitsville oh no how could this happen
[Music]
only a few months later Austin Vanessa
broke up
cheated on her of course he did I'm
telling you this guy he's a he is a
total sleaze right unconfirmed but
people are speculating
it's been reported that I cheated on her
ending a 10-year relationship
she was of age don't worry I checked her
ID
she had just turned 18.
one day ago
wait really he's dating Kaya Gerber now
mm-hmm
what the [__]
so he does like them younger it seems
how old is how much the age got there
it's probably not that bad is it I don't
know I'm pretty sure it's pretty big
really Butler oh yeah come on baby
she's it's a 10-year age Gap how old is
she she's 21. holy [__] she's young and
he's 31. holy [__] come on baby I'm 21.
I'm getting into character now listen
you wanted me to play Elvis and now I
gotta leave your old ass yeah
got me some fine Kyle Gerber 21 a little
bit older than I would like but the law
is the law
21. it's not like it used to be
fans have since pointed out that both
girlfriends have met before
oh my God
what no way yeah bro dude he is Elvis
yeah go to the next slide
dude
wait what am I this is her this is Kaya
Gerber
his old girlfriends
that's T that is t-shirts oh my God cam
on the next slide made a little
Photoshop oh my God
[Music]
so why are we talking about Vanessa
Hudson
how to get gins hunkins
why are we talking about her today well
last week Austin Butler did an interview
with The Hollywood Reporter and when he
was asked about the casting process
Butler detailed a familiar Story the
clip of Vanessa with Ryan she tells the
exact same story that he tells in this
little excerpt
here's the excerpt the month before I
play I heard that bass was making a
movie
I was going to look at Christmas lights
with a friend a friend that's right
an old hound dog
and there was an Elvis Christmas song on
the radio and I was singing along and my
friend looked over at me and goes you've
got to play Elvis
then a couple of weeks later friend I
was playing the piano that same friend
that friend Neil friend was my friend
Neil was there and I was playing the
piano she said I'm serious you gotta
figure out how you can get the rides to
a script
Justice for Austin Butler's friend of
almost a decade so he's he's not even
giving her credit you know what I mean
he didn't even why wouldn't he give her
some credit yeah that's the thing and
everybody knew that she had done that so
I don't like that mm-hmm
we don't like that uh
that Austin Butler character
Justice for Vanessa yes yes yes yes I
may have said yeah
Butler's voice teacher weighs in Austin
Butler's Elvis accent is genuine might
remain forever shut the [__] up
this guy's like my techniques are so
Advanced so deep and when I teach
someone an accent their voice changed
forever shut up
so stupid
Vanessa had something to say oh did she
she said he went to the Lady Gaga School
of Oscar campaign commented on this post
on Instagram oh she said crying yes
what does that mean like laughing like
laughing crying like I'm crying girl I
am with you she was with him for 10
years so she knows
Zach what do you say to Vanessa
uh nothing doesn't matter she's out of
the picture
yeah she's old news
Austin releases a statement to the LA
Times he needed to release a press
release Austin's uh has now credited
Vanessa hudkins
Hudgins
for helping him with Elvis roll after
receiving backlash
I was with my partner at the time
we've been together for so long as she
she had this sort of Clairvoyance moment
and so I really really just owe her a
lot for believing in me
could have said that from the beginning
douche
very interesting Elvis impersonation I
gotta say wait is this the last frame
there it is uh what a fantastic yeah
incredible report there thank you thank
you I loved that so much baby come on
I just want to thank everybody at the
Academy
[Music]
[Applause]
13 minutes
two hours 13 minutes
14 pages that's how long I waited as the
for the clock to turn 18. 14 for my
girlfriend to turn 18.
there was two hours left I was sweating
uh this one is whatever this story is
oh this dark yeah this dark one is
pretty good you got oh wait what's
mascara gate this is this printing
everywhere yeah this is okay let's do
fresh tea right here very reminiscent of
like 26. oh I know what mascara yeah
yeah yeah okay yeah so this this big
time Beauty
influencer yeah was doing an ad for it
was a big brand L'oreal L'oreal okay
everybody like mascara but she was
people are saying obviously wearing fake
eyelashes
mm-hmm and they're like this is so weird
why are you doing this ad and she she's
been denying it
seems pretty juicy let's take a look
okay
two A's where do you start
wait this is just oh I see yeah so here
the video's still up of course she got
paid for it
so this video has a million likes holy
smoke it's a big deal or is this just
because of the gossip
how big is she no she's she's a huge
deal 14 million she's like one yeah
she's like a huge makeup
okay Queen getting paid we love that for
you
you this literally just changed my life
this looks like false this is how what
is this L'Oreal telescopic lift look at
the wand
okay so basically I'm taking the curved
side and they're saying at this moment
she put on fakies towards the end of the
video here she's putting on
she has fake lashes on the other eye I
think personally it's way too long
nobody's eyelashes that long so she's
applying the mascara
and then she turns her face at one point
and the and she switches frames and then
she leaves her face like very slowly and
you can see that all of these lashes
have like duplicated okay let's take a
look can I just say real quick she
sounds exactly like Carrie Fisher Zach
just messaged me on the side because I
was thinking I was like she's just like
Carrie like older let me listen
yeah and then once you've done that you
flip the brush to the side and you use
the hook comb to basically separate this
is one coat okay I'm gonna add a second
look at the length do you see that so
they're saying it's different now so
here now when she moves over you'll see
how much longer the lashes are I am
speechless and I'm not sure
dude like it's scary man I also think
that she moves slowly on purpose like
she's she's like I'm gonna do it like
yeah it's a very slow reveal well you
can look at her eyebrow here okay it
doesn't have a lot of length and of
course it's not normal for a side
eyebrow to go that long I like that when
you yeah whatever another no screw the
Elvis Impressions the greatest carry fan
I've ever heard in my life Chad's saying
they hear it too
she got that kind of like and no offense
here it's kind of like that that voice
it's like you've been through some [__]
you've seen [__] you slept a lot of
cigarettes yeah you've done a lot in
your life that voice but I mean you know
what I mean it just kind of voice that
some people get later in life but she's
got it now and we love that for her
don't we
so here it is
poking out quite a bit
here it was before
it's when she turns that was so funny
let's watch it again I'm not sure I'm
convinced
but you gotta watch that part yeah we
have close-ups too we have images I put
together okay I'm gonna add a second
look at the length okay here I'm
watching She's even showing it off
speechless and I'm not sure anyone's
gonna they're right here to compete with
this mascara
so here's the thing this was a paid ad
but why would she what does she care if
how good you know she's doing this for
Laura give them a good yeah she wants I
guess she wants to keep getting
sponsored by them that's like if that is
what she did that's like false
advertising right yeah
okay well let's let's look at the
receipts full sabotaging I I don't know
you know what I I I don't know I'm not
ready to say fully I need more evidence
okay
so many were quick to call her out
for adding fake eyelashes filling the
comment section but Michaela tries to
double down in the replies
let's take a look
wait are you not wearing falsies at the
end no oh my God L'Oreal would never
allow me to do that but y'all proving my
point
also the fact that she starts the video
by saying this looks like false LA and
then she proceeds it's like what the f
why would you say that even
tell me which fals is used I'll buy
those bro did you add falsies at the end
we can see the length in the outer
corner
no just three four coats and my tight
liner
people think that this is the one she
used Ardell wispies
this one looks thicker than the one no
looks like Ardell whispies to me oh they
even damn these these girls are from and
they've spotted those I love my Ardell
wispies too
holy [__] how can you identify a fake
eyelash you'll see their Love of the
Game their photos it's the Love of the
Game brother
this is deep man she like grew extra
hairs yeah like you don't do that with
mascara it's just to me it's the before
like she didn't have that many lashes to
start with so it you don't go from that
to that more a vitriol no Michaela I
can't back you up on this one Michaela
I've watched you for a long time please
don't assault our intelligence like this
yeah taking it personal there
okay
so outrage uh and the fandom people are
outraged
but here's the real evidence here's the
close-ups now
let's take a close look here
at the mascara
so this is
this is without this is before
it does have some length there yeah
totally but then now we go after but
don't you think well hold on don't you
think there's more yeah there's so much
more here right exactly it doesn't if
you put like four coats over in the same
thing it's just gonna get more chunky
yeah it's just gonna get thicker wait
but she's that dumb that's the thing
people are like are you kidding why
would she start the video with these
look like false
wait can I ask questions yeah is it
possible she redid her makeup and
reapplied it and it spread out
differently or something like that
definitely not there's just too much not
like this this is like there's more
hairs there's more hairs because these
are clumped together and it just gets
more and more clumped I feel like as you
put more and more on right Olivia that's
impossible to achieve it's like
it's not even proportionate to her eye
like look how exaggerated is it possible
that it's such an amazing groundbreaking
new I know mascara you know what maybe
we gotta give it a try maybe I'll try it
telescopically we should try it
so this is before before
and again look at she's got that's crazy
oh this one has one yeah
the right can I be frank I don't like
the way this looks it looks kind of
gnarly which is why she added a Lash it
looks like spidery
yeah it looks yeah yeah
mascara doesn't end up looking that good
you know that's why I like it spidery
for some reason okay Queen after let's
take a look it's not very good there is
absolutely the volume is crazy on that
one yeah
the volume but how could she not know
that she's like a professional makeup
artist how could she not know that it
looks completely different
it's almost too stupid to believe
yeah that's why the comment was like
done in salt our intelligence sounds
like comical I can't the last picture
this shit's crazy that's common no way
no that's what you believe Okay so
Something Fishy why does it lie Joe
Rogan asks why does it look lie you got
that on soundboard I do not why does it
lie we need that I will pull that yeah
amongst those talking about it was
Kathleen Kathleen light friend of the
show friend of the show I just used her
thing today oh did you use the purpose
of purple I used her gold today too we
love Kathleen light
this is her
she uploaded the string of videos to her
Instagram stories Kathleen has never
gotten into drama before okay so she's
she's being pulled in it's irresistible
I
I feel like I'm gonna regret posting
this because I love my peers I love the
beauty community and I stay out of drama
I don't I don't want to talk to anybody
like at all
um but I was just stretching after my
workout and I was on Tick Tock and I saw
like a big influencer who like I respect
and like
she's awesome and I and I and I like her
tick tocks a lot
but I just saw a sponsored post
um I'm like
I'm like shaking because I'm so shocked
I saw her do a sponsored post which that
doesn't matter because whatever
sponsorships are awesome I do them all
the time
um but it was about a mascara and when
she shows like the finished product of
the second coat she's like wearing
Ardell Demi wispies or something like
there's falsies there like it's very
clear
it's very very clear but she's saying
that they're not falsies it's just the
mascara
I'm just like damn
that really sucks like for the rest of
us
who are so honest that really sucks
kind of disappointed me but
what can you do and you guys know yeah
so uh call it out by
I can only assume is the ultimate
Authority her being a friend of the show
Family yeah she's on top if Kathleen
light says it's fake it's fake yes
case closed end of
Michaela even brought Jeffree Star out
of retirement oh brother no
everyone's coming out to participate in
this why did you do this I'll be back to
reviewing makeup products next week
these [__] [__] can't stop lying
to their audience and it makes me sick
shut up now why you why you gotta if
nobody cares bro why are you taking
these like
chill dude
these [__] [__] so embarrassing
they can't stop why
I much preferred Kathleen's yeah Queen
status
every day obsessed with it it's so good
what product of hers were you using Ela
she gave us this eye shadow palette and
it has lots of like Browns but there's
one purple kind of like iridescent and I
love that one okay of course she's got
the best product
yeah so Michaela has yet to comment
further nor has she taken the video down
nor has L'Oreal Paris said anything
I mean look they probably paid her a
shitload of money for that so everyone's
just like I like the coverage this is
working for us
maybe maybe I'm not sure because I don't
think that makeup people are gonna rush
to buy this mascara yeah I really wonder
how I think so dude that video has like
10 mil like I don't know how many views
it has I think foreign
I just ordered it exactly oh for the
show okay yeah but I'm just saying like
the amount of views that just brand
awareness it's getting is 26 million 27
million views on that
so that's [__] crazy dude that's a
good marketing opportunity right there
but I can see why it would make somebody
else in this community upset and sad
because I mean she looks bad they don't
she's the one that lied
yeah
this is great for L'Oreal they're loving
this [__] yeah
oh my God
a remix
eyes
[Applause]
wasn't there a show like that where you
had to like sing along and stop there's
like an MTV show like read the lip sync
I'll finish the lyric or something like
that yeah
well there it is mascara gate
love it
uh I guess we we I want to leave at four
so we still have like 12 minutes so
maybe I can still hit this uh
this dark ass [__] loser this dude is
such a dark ass loser
guy in your 20s and I just saw this clip
and I was like this I don't even
remember how did we find this clip
uh I'm not sure I think you sent it in
the chat I think it was on my my for you
yeah
get a load of this [__] guy this is
crazy dude this is what all these Sigma
grind set people are on oh I wish Dan
was here because he had a lot of funny
Insight but I remember kind of what he
was talking about here if you're a guy
in your 20s and you don't have a
Lamborghini you should actually sit down
and have like a serious discussion with
yourself as to why you don't have a
Lambo because it's I realize now that
it's so incredibly easy and there's so
much money out there and 200 Grand
relative to what is out there in
circulation and what you can grab
especially now with AI tools that you
can leverage like never before 200 Grand
is Trump change if you're a guy dude
there's like trillions of dollars in
circulation all you got to do is reach
out your hand and grab it oh my God yeah
so he was mentioning AI tools and Dan
told me about there's some phenomenon
where
people
are using AI tools to
or they're like having a I write really
shitty stories about really Niche
subjects and then adding it to
to Audible
and then they use AI uh voice reading
yeah okay so for what and then people
buy it
you think of like some stupid Niche
thing right like uh
how to uh you know how to get earwax
well without [__] I don't know
whatever right okay so they go they go
to chat GPS say hey write me a you know
20 Page story about the getting earwax
out okay and then they have an AI
narrate it
and then they submit it to Audible and
people buy it
that's the thing right
that's what Dan said yeah he said yeah I
actually summed it up pretty well
so like that's is that kind of a hustle
though that's kind of a Vibe isn't it
like that's just that is kind of players
I mean if you can do that not doing
anything illegal yeah exactly there's
nothing illegal and then I don't see a
problem with it I mean you are I mean if
is it correct like I don't know yeah you
know what I mean it's a little dishonest
because it's like you're just
repackaging crap meaningless crap I
guess it yeah it is it is unethical
because you're you're sad I don't know
if I'm fully understanding it still well
if somebody's looking for a book yeah
and you're selling them this book
but it's really just repackaged AI trash
they're not buying what they think
they're buying it's misleading
but I I don't know but yeah so Dan when
you heard the AI thing he's like it's
got to be but I got real interested in
this guy and we started to look into him
a little bit
um
this guy is so [__] crazy dude
bro there's so much money in circulation
my homie is doing my homie has this
business where he like opens a fake uh
medical office and then pretends that a
bunch of old people are come doing
Medicare and we build the government
like millions of dollars bro there's so
much money out there that's what I'm
thinking like if you're talking like
that about money it's like what kind of
scam are we talking about because it's
got to be a scam whatever it is if
you're 20 and you don't have a Lambo you
need to try harder rats will dance for
money if you pay them
and that's so true Jordan finally
something wise
yeah so this guy's name is uh
Sebastian
I can't watch this clip because it's
copyrighted loser
he Sebastian I honestly don't know how
to say his last name peace and love
your Guru
yeah
what is it we we could not find it I
mean when it's been too much time
looking but it Sebastian gorgio
he's a 23 year old self-proclaimed
YouTuber real estate five-time covet
Survivor
[__] Legend dude
and most important he's a nice guy
that's his Twitter bio
you guys have this is my story from one
thousand dollars to
okay let's find out
but you're really a piece of [__] I hate
this guy can I hate messages like this
and like I mean it's very much like
Andrew Tate it's and then when you get
behind the paywall and you see that he's
saying that he's not paying taxes and
his scamming his Partners out of money
it's like yeah of course money is easy
for you to make it's if that's how
you're making it so bad
yeah
like six years or something but my name
is Sebastian Giorgio welcome to my video
Welcome to my channel most of you
probably don't know who I am because I
intend for this video to go viral and in
this video I'm going to tell all of you
guys about exactly how I went from a
thousand dollars to eight million now
keep in mind my parents are from a
communist country they're from Romania
they moved here in 1988 they came with
absolutely nothing my dad you know he
worked hard when he moved here and he
built up some money but he lost
everything in 2008 my parents got
divorced and my mom was uneducated and
did not bro if your dad doesn't have a
Lambo he seriously needs to [__]
re-examine his life
why don't you get rid of him or like
divorce him or whatever you know Childs
can divorce their parents eldad
lad speak good English so she worked at
Wendy's she worked as a maid cleaning
people's houses and she received very
little income we grew up in Detroit with
her and never mind this is boring let's
pull up his tweets I'm the cool dad now
I wrote down just like a quick breakdown
of how he got his money instead of
watching okay it's from that video so
let's see he says he made his money
um
he worked at fast food with a legend he
began flipping cars oh yeah he's a
flipper we love that yeah you're not in
a car wash place and then that's how he
got into cars he was he was uh he had
nine cars by the time he was 19. cool
well Sebastian was in real estate school
he made money by Drop Shipping oh God
that's the scammiest dumbest crap that's
how soflo makes his money
Drop Shipping means that you are selling
people on Facebook
outrageously marked up crap from Alibaba
that's what it means
foreign and I think that's pretty common
for like uh these Sigma Bros to try to
do that
but it's crazy people make some sofa
make so much [__] money in that [__]
definition Drop Shipping oh kind of just
what I said
Sebastian started a YouTube channel so
he could uh scam a bunch of suckers into
paying him
uh he started selling an online course
that gives in-depth tutorial
yeah okay who cares
what did I miss
you started a Google ad company called
digital wealth MD
which he claims is a seven-figure
company okay who cares then he got into
crypto of course
so here let's just get to his tweets
men want one thing
large mountain style home enforced by
Lake
Pleasant wife with no attitude
dab me up girl Pleasant wife with no
attitude wife
I'm so pleasant pleasant first of all
Pleasant is like
such a [__] slimy [__] word in
this context yeah never talk about my
wife in this context
you better stay Pleasant with me
three to five children what is he saying
one thing and then listing four things
am I missing something you're not and
actually you totally dunked on this one
yeah I keep reading it and I'm like what
men want one thing uh here's four things
that is so funny you stupid idiot [__]
and a dynamic gym inside of RV garage so
disgusting okay bro
uh porn is ruining young men
you know what like in a sense I agree
the porn is Cur some porn a lot of
mainstream porn is very corrosive but I
get the feeling that's not what he means
I think he's just like anti-masturbation
why is this point like so popular
nowadays
they think that is there any evidence of
like bad no effects of porn oh well
is fine I mean my the problem with porn
in my opinion is that
kids start are consuming it way too
[__] young and it it's gonna mess
with your mind in terms of like
the expectations of what a sexual
encounter is like what you're supposed
to do for the other person and this idea
of sex is is just gets super warped and
[__] up also I think kids just it
makes kids like aware of super crazy
sexual [__] way too young
so in that sense I think it's dangerous
but you know there's a lot of like I
feel really good healthy porn that's
like wholesome and nice and wholesome in
the sense that like it doesn't have like
um you know a dude choking at her out
and [__] 10 [__] coming on her I
mean that that gentleman's porn that's
fine that's fine you know that's what
you're into but there is porn out there
that won't make you nauseous I'm just a
little suspicious because I'm only
hearing about this point from like
suspicious people like Andrew Tate oh
yeah so their Theory
we talked about this yesterday on
leftovers their Theory they're returning
to like tradition into the sense like
like a really like a pleasant wife yeah
like a hundred years ago where it was
like a sin to masturbate and they think
that masturbation is like uh
a sign of weakness that you're supposed
to like hold it in or something
and um
I don't know I don't know
uh the bio so he's he's religious the
Bible is filled with so much wisdom and
knowledge it's amazing every man should
read the text especially proverbs
just had an interview with uh Prager you
I explained why feminists are wrong
where I fall politically let me guess oh
my gosh and the corruption of the world
why bro what are you doing
he's young right like this I mean I'm
sure
how many years before he goes into rehab
is it like two is it three I don't know
he's 23.
so probably another two years he'll be
in rehab
he's going to lose a lot of money in
crypto for sure that's gonna if he
hasn't already homeschooled children
just oh there's more this symbol status
status simple set [__] me status symbols
for men fit body that one's interesting
to me I never thought his fit fit body
as a status symbol but I guess it is it
means you have enough time and money to
dedicate to exercising I don't know yeah
status symbol have money okay
homeschooled children that you lost me
on bro that is not a flex that means
you're part of a really [__] up
dysfunctional family probably
kids
get you in public schools gonna drive
you crazy
here's what really happened yeah here's
what really happened during the Civil
War
one of the homeschool now I think of
like anti-backs parents that's it that's
that's like 90 of what that means
one of the biggest problems we are
facing is the generational decline in
testosterone in men men are weaker than
ever before they also have like some
weird pseudoscience about semen
retention they think that keeping the
semen in increases their testosterone
stuff but obviously there's literally
zero
zero evidence to back anything like that
yeah I found something that says there
can they quote studies that indicate
ejaculation leads to decreased
testosterone and vitamin levels but
there's no science there's
well semen is like just like a tiny bit
of protein and water and [__] like it's
not there's no essential vitamins that
are being taken trust me if you lost
essential vitamins from a masturbating
that is scurvy like [__] 15 years ago
yeah pretty quiet room okay
every time I'm not with this men I
thought that was pretty funny I'm just I
didn't even hear you joke I'm sorry I
was doing research I said if you lost
essential vitamins from jerking off I'd
have died of scurvy 15 years ago
foreign
[Applause]
they love me they really love me
it is interesting they like before my
first boxing match not just my coach but
all the coaches said like
no sex for two weeks yeah well so okay
that that is
the boxers because it gets you you know
listen psychologically it can affect you
not jerking off it makes you aggressive
it doesn't give you attention release
but so that that there's there could be
something to it but in terms of it
affecting your testosterone there's no I
don't see any way that's possible
Mike Tyson famously I remember he would
say he wouldn't have sex for like a few
weeks before a fight yeah
just get all crazy George Costanza
um he didn't have sex for a long while
and he became a genius
playing that I know
great episode
this guy's a loser that's all I gotta
say cringe
um
if he's that rich why is he hustling so
hard yeah that's what all these guys do
like you can only fool like 15 year olds
probably I don't know feel bad for those
kids
there's anyone with a little bit of life
experience in a brain will not fall for
any of this crap but you know this he
actually responded to this clip of his
going viral
he says yes it was intended I was being
a little sarcastic okay dork
please stand by your words
bro if you don't have a Lambo by the
time you're 20 you should literally just
[__] kill yourself
Nobody's Gonna Wanna [__] you dude
men literally want one thing a nice
house live by a lake a nice family a
pleasant wife a bad bank account a cool
road to live on a nice job when men just
want one thing
tough crowd in here today it's cricket
I don't like this topics and it sucks
the life out of me I feel like Jimmy Lee
up here so it's not you it's what this
guy is doing to me every time I see his
tweets
so yes
he says I was being a little sarcastic
but my intention was to go viral oh I'm
just I'm sad that this is like a popular
thing that's happening with men it is
man I'm just really sad it is it is it's
a pleasant wife that like grew up with
all this like watching these guys and
like Aiden Ross like they love Aiden
Ross and it's like they're they're lost
like my cousin every time he messages me
he's like hey I got this new scam I'm
gonna do it's like bro just go the [__]
school or figure out something else if
you don't want to do school that's
hustle culture yeah that's what this
guy's like he's like yo you're not a
millionaire by the time you're 20 you
are not scamming people hard enough yeah
exactly
it's sad
it's really really easy and in a sense
soflo Antonio was the first Sigma and
for women it's really sad
yeah I don't even want to see this [__]
you know although for for the men out
there who are loved by their parents and
well adjusted it's also not good you're
gonna have you know you'll you'll be
like the you know the one-eyed man when
everyone's blind sort of analogy
so that's cool
does that make sense yeah I guess like
the standard yeah the standard is low a
gentleman not in a school shooting way
but like you know
Elliot Rodriguez he was the never mind
so he says results from going mainstream
dude everyone's clowning on you stop
you're not mainstream 40 to 50K a free
press what okay
that's like um
that's like Harvey Weinstein being like
Yo dude the amount of Free Press I've
been getting
billions worth of free yeah crazy
biggest TV channels and Ro want to
interview
business up six to seven percent well
well
I guess
six to seven times one is what
six and seven so I guess it's easy to
multiply that they've been correction
numbers six six times one of the one and
two three
six six
[Applause]
but like three plus three he goes
I go three plus three and then he needs
to count each finger and then he goes he
goes Dad what's two plus two he goes
four and then when he tries one he
doesn't know like three plus five he'll
be like
he goes five
six
that's so funny
he loves it pretty slick little dude
yeah very sharp most new followers are
girls that want a piece
sorry ladies I'm not single
podcast requests from big people
bro you talk like
this guy is actually I you know what I
would like to talk to him on the podcast
I would love to talk to him it's
probably one of those big people
there you go all right I'm as big as it
gets number one in the world that's
right reach out to Sebastian Google
I do think that you know like Tate
really set this new yeah uh template of
just being like audacious and then
getting reactions yeah and now people
are trying to emulate that
I don't know I feel like he's giving
himself a little too much credit where
he's like I meant to go viral by saying
this insanely stupid thing yeah no in
this situation I think he definitely
just [__] up
he definitely believes it yeah yeah yeah
uh some hey reach out to him though that
would be a great calling okay you got it
Sebastian
talk to me baby maybe I can turn him
I can change him
if I can change him I can get to Aiden
I'm gonna turn this guy into a socialist
I'm sure of it these glasses have
changed my life
um
so whatever
yeah
pretty cool Pleasant wife yeah
dude you what do you even know about
life you're like 22. I better not walk
up to me
you've about to find out I'm gonna show
him how pleasant of a wife I am they
better fear you you know what would
really complete me as a human being a
subservient Pleasant wife with no
attitude yeah that's what I need to
complete me as a person
my dream partner is someone who
is quiet and doesn't question me and
challenges me in no way
she makes coffee
the way I like it
she makes me a smoothie in the morning
she's more a servant really than a
but when I really want to be with a
partner I hang out with the dudes
they complete me
but a wife is meant to be pleasant
with no attitude
and she has sex when I say it God damn
it
I smoke marijuana so I don't beat my
wife and children we're like two perfect
jigsaws that that puzzle pieces that fit
together
me
the wealthy Alpha genius and her the
subservient stupid little servant I
smoking a hot wife
you know what I'm saying
it's a perfect union
please and don't leave the house when
I'm not with you
that's just inappropriate my wife went
out for pizza without me that would be
grounds for divorce
this is his wife trying to get away
[Music]
this is his wife crashing the car in a
double suicide
hurry who's playing it now Sebastian
[Laughter]
I'm gonna drive off this [__] cliff
foreign
yeah so there it is a shout out to
Sebastian who's out there he look he's
got he's so so slow there's so much so
flow about him for sure bro if you're
not ripping off people's content and
monetizing on Facebook what are you even
doing
I've made 10 million dollars stealing
content from small creators and
uploading it to Facebook you're just not
trying hard enough different
perspectives yeah bro I literally buy
toothbrushes on Alibaba for 10 cents and
resell to soccer moms for 15 on Facebook
they have arsenic in it it doesn't
matter
they literally made with asbestos and
cyanide it literally doesn't matter bro
that's why they're so cheap
you're not trying hard enough
bro I get aloe vera from China
for five cents a bottle
I don't know what's in it but these
women love it
it's filled with like formaldehyde dude
it's crazy
I knew somebody in Atlanta that that was
how they paid the rent
um and they would buy like rock stuff
Alibaba for like 10 cents and then
resell them as healing rocks that's
[__] yeah awesome
I don't know if they work they're if
they were healing or whatever but he
definitely got a nice profit
dude that's so awesome yeah legitimately
I mean you kind of have to be a psycho
to do that because you're ripping people
off but yeah
dude I got hair dye from China for like
10 cents a bottle and I sell it on
Facebook
it's literally permanent dye dude I
don't know how it works but they can
never get it out it's crazy
it's literally just ground up Asphalt
dude
just Rocks come out of it it's all crazy
I [__] sell wigs I get them for five
cents bro it's I we I harvest that in
China they harvest the hair from
cadavers
they get it off dead bodies bro it's
crazy and dog dead dogs it's not even
human hair
I upmark it like crazy it's like a
thousand dollars I think it's premium
it's just dead hair bro
stores do that every day yeah but like
it's not the same as some dude
buying like
isn't Teddy fresh made in Asian
countries yeah I'm not talking we don't
buy our clothes on Alibaba for five
cents we manufacture it
are you fresh
wait what is this from idubbbz
oh just a side note but like I don't
know if you've seen items like messaging
garyvee or trying to get his attention
for like the past six months telling him
to box It's the funniest [__] to me like
everything everything garyvee is trying
to promote I see items in the DMS
different perspectives well garyvee is a
coward he just wants to make out with
his dad now put that phone down
that video should end anybody's
confidence in him everybody look at your
phone right now
different perspectives different
perspectives
yeah what's the announcement so okay
everybody's waited patiently for the
announcement
I am proud to announce guys
that I am starting a new business
importing
this is really crazy
you guys aren't going to believe it
we have cotton balls that we buy for
half a cent
spun from asbestos harvested from old
Chinese buildings and repurposed
and you can buy them now on our Facebook
shop
for only 10 bucks
and don't worry guys the asbestos has
been pre-wet
so the chance of it going airborne is
pretty low don't get it wet
don't get it wet
but that these cotton balls you know if
you're pregnant I wouldn't recommend
using them
or say if you have small kids don't you
keep them around the cotton balls but
they are a very good price ten dollars
and I'll tell you what
I've been using my cotton ball asbestos
cotton ball for about
a year now
I have developed a slight cough and some
chest pain but
[Music]
it's it's you can live with it
I know someone that sells healing rods
if you want to heal that uh yeah get
hooked me up I'm healing rocks
people are asking for the link it's
coming it's coming
yeah uh my huge announcement is do you
have why does it lie to uh Zach
oh no I was gonna pull it after the show
okay my huge announcement is this that's
a joke that was just a joke my huge
announcement is this
I am now selling an ebook original by me
how to pluck your ass hairs comfortably
and cleanly I am the only author on this
topic I'm the authority you can get it
on Audible now for 29.99 baby here you
manually typed it on this is all for my
brain hello and thank you
I'll do
plug your ass here's first tweezers
that's my robot voice but I ended up
sounding like one of these people
[Music]
that's a joke that's a joke the real
announcement is this
[Music]
drum roll please
I'm very excited to announce
my friends
keep the drum roll going
my very own brand
of a
asbestoside
that's right it's Ethan guaranteed it'll
kill all the bugs I bought it on Alibaba
for two cents per fluid ounce
gotta airdrop Bread on two over to you
for the cheap price of 49.99 now here's
what's special about this
uh
asbestoside why am I saying it weird I
was at pesticide
why am I saying asbestoside
here is my very own pesticide recipe
[Laughter]
so what we did is we went and found all
the leftover chemicals from that one
chemical that Kilt was killing making
birds extinct got those on super
discount what was that [__] called
anyone remember
there was a pesticide back in the day
was like making bird shells super thin
and like birds were going extinct do you
guys remember that um
it was [__] crazy they were Helen
was really famous I think y'all are too
young my old ass remembers
no but that that's just a joke
uh the real one is is that Ethan Klein
today is Drop Shipping
beef jerky
it actually drops out for about two
cents per pound
and uh this is all natural made
in the streets of China
uh we find rats that are either you know
we find rats that are either dead or
dying they're they're easy to capture
rats will down hit me with the music
Zach It Feels So Bland
yeah so there's a lot of roadkill in
China they die from the poor air quality
some Villages they just straight up
starve and what we do is we've we've
created a a work for hire system back in
China
were peasants
and villagers who have no positive
outlooks they gather the roadkill and
dead Critters and all that
and we put it into a big vat
and what we do is we heat that up to
extraordinarily High
degree DDT that was the one that was
killing birds y'all don't remember DDT
it literally was like gonna kill every
[__] bird
then what we do is we get we get a
barrel of DDT that's left over from the
90s we pour that in there
just to cut it like how you cut Fentanyl
put a little DDT in there
you know and we put some back we got
some bats in the hole we get rats dogs
cats
we burn it down
and through some proprietary techniques
which I can't share with you we end up
with a really hearty high protein very
low
incarcinogenics low and formaldehyde
very low uh some Trace levels of um
cyanide
that occurs naturally
so and what we do is we package that for
two cents a pound we drop ship that
right over to you
organic
49.99
and I'm hustling and if you're not
hustling then you're not living you
should [__] die if you're not Drop
Shipping beef jerky from China idiot
okay let's go
yes and what's really special about this
program is that we're hiring these poor
villagers they have no prospects in life
they're literally gonna [__] die and
starve and here I am paying them you
know a handsomely at one quarter of a
quarter of a cent per pound
and now you may not think that's a lot
of money is anyone listening what are we
talking about I'm talking about the
peasants who collect the
roadkillers the whole industry here
right The Peasants now I pay them a
quarter of a quarter of a Cent and that
not per pound and that may not sound
like a lot of money dude but in China
that goes a long way
foreign
if you get a big dog Big Dog Run what
like 20 25 pounds and here's the thing I
don't even some people take the moisture
out and then wait I don't do that I'm a
good guy
Chad said I blame Rebecca Black for this
it's 100 her fault here's the thing I'm
a good guy I keep the moisture in I'm
not trying to rip them off you bring me
a dog 25 pounds 25 times a quarter of a
quarter of a cent what's that put you at
yep
[Music]
so here we're in shooting range of one
penny from perspectives shooting range
of one penny we're in throwing distance
of one penny and you may not you may not
know but in China that'll get you a bowl
of rice
and sometimes that's the difference
between life and death and that's why
what I'm doing is important and that's
why uh you're supporting a um
important Mission I have
to feed Chinese peasants
Chad keeps telling me to step up what do
you want me to do
I'm enjoying this and you know one of
our greatest collectors out there in
China he's up there he's he's almost to
a whole quarter
now that guy I don't know how he does it
he might be killing the neighbor's
animals and stuff like that he might be
killing pets because frankly it doesn't
make sense how much Road killing dead
animals he's able to collect it doesn't
seem humanly possible but he does it and
I don't ask questions
and so he's almost made a whole quarter
from doing that
oh you know I'm just working that's okay
you can you can really make come up big
time on this and I've always said that
I've always and I'm a good guy like that
and so at the bot at the end of the day
you get this highly nutritious organic
beef jerky
it has no beef in it
um
right so it's actually legally have to
call it the meat jerky
okay that's technically right
and so that's going to be coming soon to
our Facebook page Facebook shop for the
low low price of 49.99
again
[Music]
clinically you're not supposed to
consume more than like a few of these a
day because it does have measurable
amounts of mercury in it Zach did you
turn me down no
uh
so you don't want to eat more than a
pack a week you may get mercury
poisoning again that's natural to these
animals uh it's not it's out of my
control how do you just go on like that
on and on well I'm a savior I'm just
helping young men make it through this
world
also
oh oh oh oh
Dan is Dan is doing something
[Music]